[Music]
welcome everyone to the h3 podcast
experience today we are sponsored by me
undo stitch fix and Felix gray the guest
is the hilarious the wonderful the
excellent machine otherwise known as
Berk right there new Netflix special out
today secret time which I've watched
loved hilarious no good you have to
watch it but after this podcast because
don't I want you you know I want I want
to watch this yeah yeah yeah yeah you
the first person I ever sent a special
to ever in my entire life yep by the way
that is scene right the machine it was
well it was must been three years ago
was it three years ago that's like one
year no no no it had to be love when you
were in here for oh when I did the
machine when I read the machine you had
to be excited me too
maybe two maybe two and a five ok this
marvelous man it was like 20 years ago
right yeah whose before the internet
that's what's really impressive and you
I was following you and I was little I
was like obsessed with you and then I
kept tweeting your videos and then you
were like hey thank you or whatever yeah
and I was like I was again you're like
you got any specials like let me send it
to you I'd never done that to anyone and
it's such an uncomfortable place to go
to to go like hey here's what I've been
working on yeah
tell me if you enjoy it and I was like
wait that was a big [ __ ] mistake I
should have let him found me online the
good stuff first and then I was like and
then you came back you're like that was
hilarious
hey la come do my podcast and I was like
oh my god I was like you come to LA on
the podcaster part is is that we had you
on yeah we had this one or probably the
best episode you were probably the first
guy here in this office we had just
about this studio we had just built this
big beautiful set we're like let's bring
Burton he's a honored guest such a great
I was flipping the tables I remember you
we were drunk we were I would have drunk
here and you said to me when you started
you go I don't really drink yeah we were
drunk by the first break it's like in 30
minutes we were drunk yeah I was
flipping the table but it was the best
episode I've ever said I can say that
without reserve because no one will ever
see it no one and it's such a shame
because it was lost to oblivion for
technical issues yeah because we were
new we didn't know we were doing and I'm
so so sorry did that happen yeah I am so
sorry but I will say we learned a lot of
things from that episode we learned a
lot from meeting you and having you on
and I want to list some of the things we
learned from you okay
yes first of all to your great credit we
it was like three hours of shooting and
you said you have to post the whole
thing unedited yeah that was like
November you were like I knew I think
you were cutting you were like all right
yeah and then I was like no no no just
roll this whole thing I can't believe we
were doing that we were thinking we were
thinking like YouTube video you were
definitely thinking YouTube video and
thinking like you're like we got to chop
it up and I was like no no no no and I
kept trying the beautiful stuff is the
in-between saying yeah it's like I love
my favorite part of podcasting is when
like something happens off mic and
you're listening and you're like but you
we were so obsessed with cutting it and
editing it down it's true that it loses
authenticity is the pop yeah and when
you're in the editing and you're trying
to edit down like a natural conversation
it's like maddening what do you you know
what I'm saying yeah you were right okay
and we always thought because we took us
a while to get there but we stopped
editing we said number two
I remember we don't get we get uber
blocks for all of our guests now
Oh oh my god I remember that so baby
you're like let I didn't at the time I
didn't even I understood there was a
burr but I didn't know anyone used
anything other than uber black and
you're like and I was like I'm gonna be
drinking I got an uber and you're like
no no I thing is that I didn't know that
there was another option so I was on the
other end but I remember we were when he
was trying to pick you up you couldn't
find you we were on the phone he didn't
speak English he's on the corner the big
guy he's got a beard I got I wouldn't
get in his backseat there were groceries
back there yeah so since that moment I
was again I want you to know we get
blacks for all of our guys and ever
since that day we've sprung for the
black I didn't and I like I like my
goobers just like I like my men
why excel blacks in exile so again
getting on it totally forgot about that
and so third and most importantly we
have not forgotten and I shall never
forget by far the most important as you
may now understand as I pull it up what
is this what is it oh I know what it is
immediately I know exactly what this is
quicksand porn yup
when we were having our last
conversation it's the one it really
sticks out as we were talking about all
the weird [ __ ] we find on YouTube
you're like I'm into this thing
quicksand and I was like whoa yeah what
is that
what's so and then well I'm so happy
that kind of we get a chance to redo
this because I got the opportunity to
look it up yeah now we can have a
pleasure I'm watching it together yeah
please let's think I know this one was
only like 30 out there how did you find
quicksand porn I don't think I think I
first heard about it on like a radio Lab
and they were like and they were talking
about quicksand porn and I was like
what's so interesting sure I used to
have a joke about like the premise was I
always thought by this age I would have
been trapped in quicksand a couple times
by now because growing up quick Sam was
like everywhere and now they're just to
put this out there there is a comedian
who has a joke like that I never really
told mine but I told it like but Ian
bagg was the only person ever heard it
Ian bagg hilarious comedian one time
said the best quicksand joke ever he
walked in and my hat was on the floor
and he walked anyone huh quicksand got
him huh is this a great that's pretty
yeah no but quicksand was in everything
I ever smart growing up Abbott Costello
every like every everything was
quicksand was always the damsel in
quicksand oh and I had an obsession with
this is a young man's fetish yeah no no
it's like you got to be like 45 okay I
explained because that was like how did
you come out like how do people come up
with that as you bring across no no no
it's based in like the same [ __ ] that
like there was a TV show called the
boogaloos when I was a kid and like
every episode they tied up the girl
so like that so I remember going to this
I was a dominatrix game for a day on
this old show I had and the conker no no
Herbert I don't hurt Bert and so I was a
dominatrix kept with this lady mistress
Isabella and she did a bunch of stuff to
me and at the end of the day I was like
I was like you know I got a balance with
you not a lot of it I didn't find sexy
at all but there was a couple things
where I found like really high schools
how are you at the time I must have been
like 30 maybe she was like check out
this video and it was all stuff dialed
into my site like the stuff that would
have been enough
formative yeah what was the stuff it was
like superwoman a poor outfit oh one
dude when I first saw Wonder Woman I
remember being a kid and I was like I
was like oh I'm straight like the other
day we were in uh we were in Hot Topic
my daughters were into that kind of like
anime stuff and there was a Wonder Woman
bathing suit right and I was like I was
like honey let's get this for you she
was like it's made for girls like I'm
aboard like a 48 you're a woman I'm
gonna look disgusting I was like you're
what I got let's do yeah but so yeah so
quicksand was like the thing and then I
watched the thing I listening on radar
but then I start going I can't be a real
thing it's gotta be a joke all right
and then I googled it one night and it
was just the it was like a weird like it
stopped I don't know it's just like was
something I was like that's kind of sexy
the point when the girl's boobs get to
the mud reminded me of like every time
the dams will we get to the mud and her
boobs would lift naturally you know as a
kid you be like oh my god just connected
with that though right yeah well okay so
the thing that really threw me off at
this is that like a lot of them the girl
it she like dies tenda day in like the
fetish like she straight up she just
disappears into the Oblivion and they
and they hold that shot for a while
don't worry do I go how long's she been
under yeah like and wait and like legit
like dude I've seen some really weird
ones like with it like these now that I
said it out loud what happens is all
these dudes that make them hit me up nah
I'm gonna check out my quicksand videos
oh you got hit up by those ain't
community oh quit by sinkers they're
called sinkers their anchors yeah
there's like a legit community Wow of
people they're all older gentleman good
thinking these days
yeah maybe today maybe we can change
that maybe we can introduce everyone I
want to keep infused some new blood into
this community it's it's like 20 years
olds going what the [ __ ] oh here we go
I've got a whole I mean I've got oh if
you have the good one oh sure I'll tell
you which ones are good I here
twenty-one minutes of it well here I'm
gonna skip forward sexy girl here she is
this was like oh man I don't know what
I'm uh that that top is troublingly low
for this family-friendly show
let's cut this was good actually this
one is quite graphic so I don't want to
get too she's in a bathing suit for
Christ's sake give me a break right I
mean what are we [ __ ] what is this
the Catholic Church look a bit I'm
trying to not show too much I want to
cut I want to cut to the money shot aka
when she dies wait I don't know is she
perishing this one this [ __ ] is so
bizarre this is so bizarre by the way
this you're like can you sit back I
can't either so so I don't think she
perishes in this one so let's look look
at this in the birds that's Christ is
real so here we go
so this is the one where they perish at
the end and these these are these are
the ones that I cherish here she is it
starts almost like a Thrasher Oh see
this is Rosie's walking through the
woods yeah you get the whole story
yeah are you out of your mind
you had two very good ways to walk
around that so there's one she likes in
this one she's actually like yeah I
think is gonna shoot she's going quick
where she's like I'm dying somebody help
me this is not a joke yeah she's like I
know you're there we go this is gonna
get really sex you know your hair back
there she
I can't see the frickin bar but I want
to find a money shot where she parachute
she's struggling man so here we go
looks a little bit like work Oh get your
dicks out everybody by the way this
isn't the part that turns me off I've
already stopped watching you gotta watch
that her breaking character and be like
Darrell for real funny anymore man
that's what really turns me on when it's
they instruct them to break the wall so
it looks like actually that yeah by the
way it should be noted she didn't even
take a breath now let's see oh yeah okay
what's crazy is that this got me into a
spiral a quick fan and there's a video
online of this I think he's like a
brittle British journalist out where
quicksand is out and like the aisles
like somewhere in the coast I'm real
yeah and he's like he's like alright so
the quick son he is pretty dangerous and
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna I'm gonna
demonstrate how you get in and out of
quicksand I've got all the safety guys
we're gonna be fine so first of all get
in your wig around a little bit alright
and then you go in a little lower while
this is happening quick is having a lot
quicker than I thought alright maybe
getting me out and they spend three
hours trying to get him out of quicks
you he is terrified anyone thinking how
high up does it go I can't I honestly
think it gets to his chest yeah but he
can't breathe and he's like having and
I'm watching this I'm watching it like
you know there's Russian kids that hang
off the side of a building
yeah I'm watching it like that going I'm
going
it's long usually by know he doesn't die
part of me is like holy I started doing
I started doing a solo podcast because
of videos like that where I do too I do
one with like yes like you or love but
the open tabs yeah open on it and I just
do other types of [ __ ] I like of like of
[ __ ] I'm interested in it's always flash
floods but like but like I that kind of
stuff blows my mind like when you find a
video like that you're like oh no I mean
I loved
open tabs by the way because I always
have like a million yeah yeah it's a fun
game that we used to play I used to play
with guys is like you'd go in and just
open your browser like this and go go
ahead ask me what I've been googling
just flip through and be like oh tell me
about Kevin and bean I go oh well beans
a guy that's you know you're not in
studio Oh tell me about Rich Eisen no
tell me about alright but yes so that's
the podcast but I love finding a good
video no III never imagined my and my
whole life that I and I've feel like
I've seen everything so I'm wondering do
you have any other strange bizarre
phenomenons that you're on to YouTube
right now that's really picking your
interest or your penis or though dude
I'm the cool one of the coolest things
I've seen in a while do you ever heard
back door back room casting couch that's
the porn porn ya got I saw one of the
outtakes where the girl says no and it
was so awesome
wait that's not that's the owner that's
not the point of that nothing happens
but it's so awesome are they like why
are you here is it for she just sits
down and he does his spiel this you've
heard the spiel so I'm not the director
myself personally I'm just a casting guy
I send this out to the producers they'll
hire you and they just want to make sure
you can perform a camera that you're
comfortable right okay yeah he's like so
what I'm gonna ask you to do is first
undress and then the best part of that
whole video series is that look on their
face where they're like okay what like
pay me now and he's like good and then
you see him on his heels like that's not
how it works
confident where the whole series is like
does it ever go anywhere no it's so
great you guys I was like more of though
you find that I just I think on YouTube
to put back room casting couch fail or
something fail oh it's on porn how
better not click yeah yeah Tony Robbins
I can watch any video he does because
he's a sociopath Tony Robbins freaks me
out
because on one hand like he I get it
yeah yeah I've heard him he's got like
this magic he's like he is a sociopath
he's got that cult charm
he's a beacon jump he could make you eat
poison apple sauce and catch a [ __ ]
comet behind the moon or whatever he
could do that a hundred percent right
he's got a arey he's got a video of him
showing off his house in Fiji right mmm
and he's showing it to the camera and
it's just like do you ever like the best
way to say this is like do you ever have
a friend who gets genital warts and
every conversation they have all they do
is kind of slide in statistics about how
common genital warts are just like you
know HPV is interesting I am yeah go to
the very end and watch the way he Mike's
going on I can't see it for some reason
I'm I'm not ready but you was covering
the let me try to address this okay what
he's right here - I'll tell you I can
he's basically saying he's got heart
he's a very integral part of this
community that's really his family they
call him big boss but this is what I
call them big boss that's fun but the
best part is he forces everyone to stop
what they're doing come out to the
driveway and sing a song to him and he
stands in the middle as they sing at him
and play the guitar and you look at some
guys like I gotta get back to cutting
trees ok Tony let's do this what just
play a little and you'll see them apples
though he's in great shape
by the way I'm am saying all this and I
understand that he's never sold himself
as anything other than what he is ok
yeah well being hypocritical is I mean
yeah we watched the documentary but and
what it's pretty incredible the thing is
like that there's a documentary on
Netflix about him that was a definite
puff piece but you can't help but aside
the insanity of it so as hard as they
try to make him look like a saint you
can tell how weird it is also oh he's
good right dipping pool outside his
house yeah yeah they've been pull he's
got a little he's got a little
trampoline that he hops on yeah he makes
the girl break up with her boyfriend on
the floor
now I was like dude that's the one I was
what's life gonna be like when she gets
out of here I'm like that Rolla and he
calls back he's like what the [ __ ] was
like sorry we're okay I just got peer
pressure doing it on live TV he's like
he does this [ __ ] where he looks pretty
broken afterwards like what's [ __ ]
that part [ __ ] me up oh that wasn't
cool Tony Robbins do it but it's like he
does this Ted wear a nightgown he's like
you know he's not good for you right
yeah so you're gonna call him right now
while everyone's watching the cameras on
you and tell him you don't love him and
you never and you never loved it yeah
that woman he doubt that for me I go if
I hears biggest problems like I know
self-help gurus like I know them and I
just go what what about the day before
you were so PO you ruined you were
looking for help like him I just know
they're walking paradox and you know
this guy is the most [ __ ] I mean if
this guy he's got a [ __ ] dungeon he's
got theirs
he has like nine different beds around
his house just keeps going this is my
outdoor bed where my beautiful wife and
I la tell me this is where we make love
passionately it doesn't have like
gigantis ism he's got like a he's got
like a disease that makes him like huge
and his voice crazy we couldn't kill him
if he was passed out in a hotel room
with bats okay not much bigger no no he
has gigantis ism I think so he's a
massive man yeah his teeth fit in his
mouth like you don't have like baby
teeth oh is that true think he has a
hormone thing there's something in this
you know he's in great shape he's got to
be on testosterone he's come to ask me
about my family and then I'm gonna reply
the way Tony Ryall and Bert tell me
about your family
Oh
they call me Big Daddy Kane which means
I'm the [ __ ] he laughs like it's like
not his idea but they're like dad he's
like excuse me but he's like keep going
big you mean Big Daddy boss the way he
just laughs said that was so creepy they
call me big bosses I'm the big boss what
am I gonna do pay for everything I mean
you know as a god complex
[Music]
dude I got [ __ ] to do he's like he's
doing this gets out of here everyone put
on your Hawaiian shirts and Lane no they
put flowers in the hairs you think those
guys had them in there naturally no the
entire staff gathered to bid Tony feel
world just spontaneously what I love
right and compassion shoes because
they're gonna miss him they're gonna
miss cleaning up after him and you can
care of him and take the cars there it's
such a joy and a pleasure getting his
breakfast ready seeing that he only ate
half cos he's only watching sighs to
throw away brand-new a yeah don't [ __ ]
it don't you eat that you go don't you
[ __ ] eat that in the garbage I'm a
total hypocrite because this is exactly
how I behave about this much money
you're not a hypocrite because well he
acts like he's Saint John the Divine
yeah you know the big guy with the fan
in his hand like he's just like get me
the [ __ ] out of here damn this is
amazing why do they even try to spin it
like this wait this is just his house
these [ __ ] just work at his hat
is it a resort this is your house these
are your slaves he has slaves
yes Viji slaves meet up front mr. Tony
Big Daddy is leaving 7:00
be there dress up bring your little
flower fan we got a baby I love a baby
in the shot you know what happens when
you miss 7 a.m. they just spontaneously
met on the driveway to say goodbye why
would you show this off this is
embarrass this is embarrassing
this is embarrassing more that's scary
these are coming in the Bahamas very
much I mean this war resort there all
the time this is his house he's probably
there one month a year if a month
I mean think of his schedule there's no
way he's making it all the way to feed
woman do they have to pay tribute i
watch this is really in love with his
lot no but it's not sex it's about buddy
have a gray there tribute to the king I
don't know you know battling the day the
King got the [ __ ] the bride before the
groom that's with that's what's that
called a fornication under consent of
the king monkey he's fornicating under
the king interest by the way if we do
get end up in a in a hate spiral in life
Tony Robbins is never pulling us out
we do need self help like I'm glad you
got here he's leaving you want to sing
yeah he's like maybe you'd like if I
fornicated with your wife first like
shut up Tony you got you own slaves
[Applause]
[Music]
they make them rehearse this these are
just people look at your house and they
were her singing songs the lyrics are
white devil you could buy in the gym wow
that was really something man I'm glad
you shared that you have you are today
you have gems you you bring gifts this
is a gift I love this summer this is
really the stuff that I live for
Business Insider's they really crack the
story Robbie he got in trouble recently
for like a me to think what was it oh
not not a me no he didn't get me to but
he said something at one of the
conferences were what was it like it was
nowhere in comment was like a victim
shaming thing I'm not familiar coming up
familiar with it because I will not
misquote now we're not really just keep
we're gonna break you can totally Mel we
did for bright if just go for Majid Lee
yeah I just start every stay with
allegedly I'll call the show allegedly
so let's take a quick break and when we
come back okay
Tony you are not gonna believe this
footage of Tony Robbins me to allegedly
stay tuned
hila do you know what I value as much as
anything in this life what my dick and
my balls okay you wear nice shirts you
wear nice pants you got to feel good in
your clothing right so why is it that
people think they can neglect underwear
why is it that when your dick and your
balls are probably your most prized
position they call them the jewels for a
reason you just throw them in whatever
you've got that's unacceptable and me on
DS knows exactly what I'm talking about
that's why they make the softest most
breathable incredible fabric with
designs that are a total blast and a
total breeze to wear so comfortable so
incredible me undies Oh how comfortable
can undies be ethan micro modal do you
understand how soft and luxurious this
is balls and dick need a place to live
that's me undies Creed that's our
mission statement because the balls in
the dick it's not needed for men thank
you did I just sniff underwear they're
clean by the way I'm like that good
here's the deal they gotta they've got a
new membership plan for all those dirty
hole Rhett and disgusting underwear
you've hung on to throw that crap out
each month
Mandy's released a new exclusive print
that only members can get collaborations
with artists brands unique designs
you're gonna want to have it members pay
less for everything on the Mandy's
website with special member pricing that
means you can get a second pair whatever
you want you're gonna be paying the less
than any of these other schlubs
membership comes with no strings
attached switch any ding time cancel any
time skip a month you know they've got
that 100% satisfaction guaranteed boy if
you don't like it send it back and
they'll put it in the incinerator and
give you a full refund
can't beat that offer or can you cuz
here's a better offer first-time
purchasers when you go to Mandy's
dot-com slash h3 you get 15% off and
free shipping on your first order it's a
no-brainer folks you got a no money back
you got the money back guarantee you get
the best underwear ever made you get a
15
percent discount that's me undies cop /
h3 me Andes come / h3
all of you guys don't have an ela like
me to dress me every day and before I
had an ela I needed all the help I could
get stitch fix is your virtual ela
here's how it works
you go on your website you answer a
bunch of questions about your taste your
budget all what kind of garments you
like looks as I say garments now I own a
clothing company I started saying
garments you go you tell them everything
about yourself and then all of a sudden
they put together a wardrobe a stylist
okay someone with taste unlike you puts
together a style for you in your budget
wonderful clothes that you they then
send off to you to try on you try it on
you see if you like it guess what if you
don't like it you send it back you don't
have to pay for it it's convenient as it
gets you got someone with taste helping
you out that's not your mom and your
girlfriend do you don't have because
life is tough and sometimes you need
help
that's what stitch fix is all about so
you can look good you know it's like
it's a catch-22 you got to look good to
get the girl you need the girl to look
good stitch fix is breaking the vicious
cycle okay that's what it's all about
guys that's why I think it's a great
service that you're gonna freakin love
stylist fees only twenty dollars which
is applied as a credit towards anything
you keep so pretty much free in other
words all right here's the deal
hurry the stitch fix calm slash h3 the
get started right now keep all five
items in your box and you'll get 25% off
your entire purchase nice that stitch
fix a.com slash h3 suit fix comm slash
h3 break the cycle get the girl
look we all spent a lot of time in front
of screens that's just what we
Millennials do I was born with screens
but now I'm finding out I've read I
heard this report just last week that
the blue light emitted from screens oh
can cause strain it can mess with your
vision well now they think that it can
actual cause cancer and loss of vision
at old age are you freaking kidding me
these blue lights need to get the Frick
out and that's what these Felix grey
glasses are all about they have
technology embedded in the lens to block
those nasty blue lights from getting in
those beautiful precious eyeballs of
yours I do always feel like tired at the
end of the day like my eyes are tired
it's the blue light they're like little
Isis particles and you're the free world
your eyes are the free world block them
put up a wall you look that's what these
glasses do seriously they're design okay
to stop the strain prevent the cancer
and to keep you doing what you love
which is watch hentai at 3:00 a.m. to
8:00 a.m. every evening while your
parents sleep keep doing it and lovely
I'm sorry
and I do watch hentai though when you're
asleep you just don't know the callback
guys protect your self you don't need a
prescription their glasses are available
in non prescription readers and they
just launch prescription lenses so
everyone can benefit from wearing these
beautiful technological amazing glasses
guess what they're made of Italian
acetate the same glasses that the big
boys wear you're a big boy aren't you
these are beautiful and stylish and
they're made in that towel well I don't
know if they're made in italia but
they're made with italian acetate so oh
if you don't want i can sir
i don't know what bigger of a cell you
can get than that go to felix pray
glasses dot-com /ht to try pair Felix
glasses today
sit down for an evening at the computer
get a pair of these try it on and see if
your eyes don't feel a million times
better
that's Felix great glasses calm /h three
Felix grey glasses calm /h three build a
wall and keep Isis out those are the
blue
and your eyeballs are precious last
bastion of democracy
and we are back Tony Robbins shocking
footage that you will not believe at the
Democratic National Convention who the
this is the best friend of mine oh my
god that is huge just to give you a
scope of the amount of people to come
and watch this guy with gigantis ISM
talk express himself his giant heart you
know at least these people are going
into a stadium and saying I'm broken
right like as opposed to other people
what other stadiums fill up with people
that are broken that they don't let you
know they're broken
yeah right right okay you're right you
by the way and again I just want to
emphasize okay we're good friend on
demand Tony Robbins well I was that
doctor man I was like wow eally said
that's a really nice thing to do for
yourself to go there and learn about
yourself yeah that being said he does
own slaves so you gotta take the good
with the path yeah thank guys like was
the big play that just came out Andrew
Jackson Andrew Jackson was Hamilton was
it animals in black you need a real life
yeah we see the president Hamilton was
now right now I knew the answer to this
work I'm a bird I didn't know either no
he wasn't black he was a white guy as
one fellow white what am I crazy yeah I
just talk is he good freestyle he was he
was however it was Puerto Rican wasn't
he in the nobody is he was born in like
Puerto Rico wasn't really that's true
was Hamilton land that got shot by burr
yes he got he died in the duel yes do
they put that into play yes really
yeah with Tupac's who shot you exactly
burr does a drive-by he's like oh [ __ ]
and then Suge Knight comes out and
[ __ ] sets off of throws a grenade in
the audience or
so we admit that these people it's good
for them that they're going out and
they're getting help yes god bless them
and it's great that Tony can provide
that kind of help for people yeah but
but there's a big but but but also well
also we'll spend this life thing like
let's just say oh he's not that woke
he's not that whoa yeah budday but you
know it's like these retreats they cost
like ten thousand dollars and people are
like getting loans and selling their
[ __ ] these are poor people that are
looked are desperate you know to improve
their lives I'm like Tony you're a rich
man and heat what he would say is it's
important to make that sacrifice so the
experience is more worth it for you it's
easy for him to say when he's getting
$10,000 he would say the same thing
thousand but it was a lot maybe five
maybe fifteen mm-hmm could be more look
I almost did it is ten thousand what
it's his business mastery I mean maybe
he has different ones but yeah that's
the ultimate retreat it's like a
week-long they even give you lunch they
even give you lunches well they give you
a little black lunches no but Tony would
say the same thing he's like listen if
it's you're not payment I'm really not
gonna be worth my time okay
okay I'm gonna flip on you and I'm
starting to side with Tony I like that
it's $10,000 make it hurt
earn it that's what he said you know
that's such a nice thing to say when
you're the one receiving the money my
wife said I can't give you [ __ ]
anymore your dicks too big and I was
like well can't argue with that
Wow it's the same logic that Tony's
giving is it you you should always pay
more so that it would work more and
you're like losing a logical connection
like is he saying that Tony doesn't want
to do it nope he's saying and so
brilliant marketing I am charging so
much it that it works yeah if I if I
charged us you wouldn't appreciate it
yeah so if your wife says I don't want
to suck your dick anymore cuz it's too
big then you're it's I'm in the same
place as a Tony Robbins customer cuz she
he's big [ __ ] him
he's big [ __ ] him he's going I'm
sorry guys
if you're in small dick sorry
but you got such a big dick yeah all the
way my dicks not that big right yeah but
yeah that's it's genius bucket marketing
right guys I charge extra for my shows
because I will remember that help I got
I you'll remember me for a long time as
you pay off that debt for the next five
years you'll remember every time you
make that payment every time you know
the bus and go I had to sell my car
exactly you'll go oh that's right yeah
now I don't have a car and I'm still
depressed yeah I thanks Tony
no I don't know god bless him right but
anyway we were talking about this clip
we failed to find it guys I click baited
you on that break we have nothing to
show you well what do we have here long
to find the moment but let me let me
paraphrase in 11 he had said I remember
what he said in one of these giant
auditoriums he said they were talking
about me too and he said you know it's
gone too far
he says I think me too is too much about
the victim and you don't want yourself
to be the victim you need to take
control of your own life so all these
people being like me too me too it's
like you need to take control for your
own healing and your own life and stop
being the victim that's fine I get where
he's coming from I could see what here's
where he offended people he said for
example it's gone too far I work with
CEOs who just told me this anecdote they
said I had two people applied to be my
secretary one was a very beautiful woman
who was more qualified and the other was
a dude who was less coiffeur than the
other beautiful woman and I heard the
dude because I don't I think it's
dangerous to hire a beautiful woman and
they don't want to be near an attractive
woman there is and I was like whoa how
about just don't [ __ ] grab her tits
or how about don't ever mention that out
loud just hire the dude and be like yeah
I guess he can fight it in Tony and then
Jimmy was like by the way this guy Tim
something who works for charles schwab
said this to me I get I understand I
understand I understand what he's saying
I worked with the young lady Jessica
Michelle singleton very talented in
Cleveland and then the night the club
gives me like 12 beers because I'm going
back to my room all I got to do next day
is go out to
Morning Glory the Rovers got a big
festival that's all I got to do go out
there and party yeah and I say to her
which I'd say to any comic I'm in the
elevator with her and I'm like I'm about
to say you know let's go to my room
that's it it's any comment yeah anymore
right man I don't and and then part of
me goes yeah BC just a comic who's gonna
talk about comedy in your life you know
everyone Aaron so I get it we're get out
of the elevator go I made it so [ __ ]
uncomfy I was like I'm married but hold
it hold it and then put my finger like I
made it so uncomfortable than she was
like I need a beer right now to hear the
rest of his speech and I was like listen
I would just say hi but like I wanted
someone to drink with I don't want to
just go and drink my myself and I want
to talk about comedy and she was like
are you trying to invite me to your room
and I go no that's not what I want but
yes that is what I want like as a comic
not a [ __ ] like oh my god and it just
spiraled I was like I want to go back to
the day where I could just say it and
then not hit on you and be a good guy
yeah so did you go back to the room oh I
[ __ ] her obviously but no we my back
of the room I mean whatever
I mean basically bring her back to the
room that's fine just whatever you do
don't stand in front of the door and
don't pull down your pants and jerk off
[Music]
don't know ever that was the lowest ek
yeah and the saddest because it's like
so weird and not worth it to lose such a
comedy like a hero will be not kill be
better yeah he'll be back he lost some
he'll have insane mass but masturbation
joke is when he comes back his first
joke he says he's gonna be one of the
best jokes you've ever heard in your
life
are you saying that for sure you have a
into a sense I just know him he's a
brilliant he's a brilliant game like
he's a brilliant mind he has been
sitting by himself with his thoughts
mm-hmm for the past 1 in 5 months 4
months hasn't like it's not like he's
been on a timeout that long and he won't
come back for a while but when he starts
coming back he will get will get like uh
it's like when Artie Lange after he
stabbed himself right
and he first time he got back on stage
oh he said no so how was everyone's
Fashion Week like if you give him that
much time he's gonna come back with
something that's [ __ ] insane yeah and
I bet and we'll hear it in the
communities we'll see him work out bits
yeah but when he does that special that
he'll pay for himself will release
himself not everyone will buy it which
is fine I'll definitely buy it and I'll
sit oh I will I feel like he was the one
guy that was immediately like I
definitely did all the things he owned I
was like wow pretty aggressively that's
a what that's almost quicksand level of
fetish you know I mean you want coming
up my room and then all the sudden hey
you wanna come on my room okay here we
go
yeah that's okay for you huh do you mind
if I check off the sand from the door
here's well here's the question right
like this it and by the way this is a
really slippery slope to even bring this
up to even suggest this but like say
that is what you're sorry say that is
your fetish right yeah is like say that
that is the one thing that turns you on
is masturbating in front of and they
can't escape no no no no just say
masturbating in front of me okay let's
simplify let's just say masturbate in
front of people that's the thing that
turns you want right right how do you go
about your you better you hire a
prostitute you oh yeah yeah yeah I mean
and then you don't realize what you're
saying like I said to someone the other
day I go I go here's just I didn't even
begin to finish I said to my wife
friends I said hey we're talking about
something I go well here's the problems
like I was talking about kiddie porn
they're talking about kiddie porn I go
yeah but what about this is that these
guys that would be pedophiles at least
they're just watching kiddie porn and
then my wife goes
what about the children in the same
video and I'll say oh yeah good point
good I didn't think it through
[Laughter]
exactly
like you say I don't know but
you can I mean you can find a consenting
person right I guess that was his move
is that he would be like do you mind if
I masturbate from I guess it's also the
places he did it was at work the problem
is if I do it at a bar and no one calls
foul are you fine a random girl and you
go on a couple day maybe he doesn't like
the dates it's just the random hey how
you doing Bob's your uncle god bless see
you later yeah but I think the problem
was that they were familiar and they
were working in a way it was a power
structure yeah like hey do you mind if I
jerk off in front of you and you're like
wow and I remember saying to my wife
when that went down and buy this by the
way this is just honesty and if you're
through the roof about me sharing
honesty I apologize but this is I'm just
talking I said two more if I go I go but
why didn't they just say no like why
didn't they just walk away and my wife
goes okay let me role play it for you
Brock Lesnar and you and I are in a
hotel room and he's like hey do you mind
if I jack off she's like do you can give
an option in there yeah good call also
it's just so startling of a question
yeah and I bet you're you're probably
like wait is this gonna be a joke yeah
sure like yeah go ahead
and then all the sudden he drops trou
and you're like whoa what do I do now
and then it's already started you're
like okay already yeah do it yeah yeah
it's just a weird situation
yeah by the way I'm a fan of Louise I
love I mean yeah I actually find my I
found myself thinking about him like if
you're you remember like a week ago and
I told you I hope that I hope he has
some good friends around we'll keep him
like you know like I mean it's probably
going through like the worst time
possible they took away I mean like like
this yes the Otters like yeah so bad I
just talk about my wife jacking me off
in my special and my daughters will see
that and be like mom's not good at it
yeah I did see that by the land and jobs
can be they can be a tug sometimes she
tried to give me one the other night and
I was like nah I think I'd rather just
go to bed unsatisfied just go to sleep
yeah she was like trying to problems but
what if I turned off all the lights I go
yeah like a ghost is jacking me off yeah
wait
yeah no I yeah I can't
by the way secret time available now on
Netflix yeah definitely check it out you
all have Netflix everybody has Netflix
watch secret time thank you
after this podcast you can watch it now
you get the free world anyway I do
actually I did want to ask you so I have
a whole lot to get to but since we're
talking about secret time now on Netflix
Bert Kreischer we had spoken I saw you
do a gesture and in the special where
you're talking about the Alabama wet
wipe okay and but that the joke was
great but what piqued my interest was
this my god is that when you when I I
didn't I it's so natural cuz I wiped
from the front I went from the front I
went from the front I'm a front way yeah
thank you okay
because the kids do they go high five
ago discriminated against for front
wiping I've been ostracized yeah I ain't
feel like I am at the forefront of an
important movement real yeah oh that's
so I always like a 'then he just wiped
from the front and I feel if I'm being
and I don't want to flour this up and
make a hyperbolic statements but I feel
like Rosa Parks of the wiping movement
for men I can I tell you the word I
always thought I'm a forerunner yeah I
was telling a forerunner of wiping yeah
if you lift the balls when you wipe yeah
I lift and pull to the side I'm getting
that old you know I'm right and I wrap
you can wrap them around the hand as I
go in and I go in and add it I like like
you're lighting a match right like I go
I don't go I don't drag or ooh the gooey
[ __ ] Oliver balls oh yeah dragon it's
like yeah I said oh don't you wipe [ __ ]
up your back what's wrong with you I've
been doing this for decades
I literally cannot wipe from the back I
do I try it's instant what do you stand
up if you walk in on me wiping I look
discreetly I bring feeling like I'm a
chilling girl ways from the back a just
goes
imagine you have to and you look at your
toilet when you're wet you have to stand
up there's not that much space back now
get [ __ ] on your ass the front half you
know you like your vagina from the back
you ladies do that because you're not
you know you wipe your vagina from the
back cuz you don't want to risk the lady
opportunity of something from the like a
germ the ladies the ladies are supposed
to pull it back everything away from the
that's what the ladies do but I thought
you went from fronts back backs can I
tell you Anna please always this
conversation was sprung at at one time I
was in college with all my friends and
my friend one of my friends was telling
a story about how he had a friend with
one arm and I said Wow how does he lift
his balls up when I'm alive and I was
with like four other friends and they
all went and they all were back wiping
Psychopaths and they all said what
they're like no joke showery to be in a
time machine in that room with you guys
and the look on your face well everybody
was making fun of me because they were
all back wipers and the thing that was
crazy about it is that we didn't know
each other existed there are two types
of people in this world right and they
don't know they existed until I'm again
the Nelson Mandela of ass white dude and
I've opened this dialogue thank you I
hope that when people like us and we can
share our own secret okay yeah I and I
took a poll on Twitter today cuz I
wanted to get to the heart of this yeah
sixty percent from the back forty
percent from the front so we're not that
rare species that's almost
perfect split I once brought it up on
stage because I went I did the did the
joke and someone goes oh you why from
the front I don't even think of it done
even it's just how I wipe and I go you
know how do you wipe and the guy goes I
sort of got to goes side to side that's
the most fun what I go but where does
your hand enter he goes it doesn't
matter its side to side was this a bit
of a heckle no it was in Atlanta it was
in Atlanta and I was like wait wait yeah
I'm I have always been and here's the
other thing is my dad we talked about if
I talk about this with my family hmm
my dad goes all who wipes from the front
and I go dead you taught me how to wipe
my ass oh yeah the first time I did it
why didn't you stop me then and put me
on your right path this is where a man
my dad had the same conversation because
he the podcast and he goes I failed you
as a father unless I said that this week
and I'm like I'm your son dude I don't
know how I learned to lift up my balls
and scoop out the shed yeah I've picked
that up from somewhere or maybe you
didn't [ __ ] teach me yeah you did
fail me yeah and by the way my method of
wiping that I learned on my own is
better it's okay [ __ ] yeah high-five
[ __ ] yeah my way of being way of wiping
is so much better superior yeah you
can't get the [ __ ] out you go wet you
and wet or un dry you pure dry or do you
use a baby way oh I'm its Alabama wet
wipes you actually do that yeah it's a
[ __ ] kidding me it serious try it when
heals when you're not a hairy [ __ ]
yeah but doesn't stick okay so we're
gonna get into the cynics of this yes
when you're in a bind okay
road trip gas station the paper toilet
paper like this panting legit right
scrolls on fold it fold it fold it you
need a clean side you need a straight-up
clean side right fresh piece of
loose-leaf
just a little bit of a spit it's cool if
it's got a little bit of a little bit of
consistent now you hear me out it's my
[ __ ] okay I drink some water and then
go in and just give it a good one don't
go back and forth out of coz that's when
you start losing paper and our ass hairs
so the I think what you were you're at
pages that you're using the Torah paper
as you described roll papers yeah would
maybe think of the Torah exactly I don't
use the Torah but yeah and then but now
I'm not
I got the water spraying toilet okay you
got the bidet yeah was that from Tom its
brief like two years
didn't wipe I've I've had days where I'm
like i'ma roll it I think I got
everything
ah you get [ __ ] streaks on your on your
bear I don't want where oh you guys just
sent your pants another dark I don't
know I'm a foreigner and was that at Tom
Segura thing he had a boy I know he got
the bidet first and I went to his house
I walked into his bathroom and it wasn't
open like hey man you dreamin right I
came out yeah I think anything to him
and he goes I go dude he goes I know
it's amazing yeah well where did you get
that he was like dude gave me the name
of his place we redid our house and I
told my wife I go I want one of those
toilets but I had seen them in Japan I
gotten them in Japan no so obsessed with
them in Japan then I would sometimes sit
on my toilet and relax and just have it
hit me in the bottle they're just going
oh for all the years that didn't hold
them just so we had this conversation
with mom and a company sent us one of
these toilets but what's the name of the
place I know the place it's the same
ones we got no way yeah I just need to
install it yeah it's a little
complicated or storm I need a plumber
you need a plumber and you need
electrician I don't still yeah because
you gotta have a blue man job uh-huh
well yeah don't you wish you could I
mean you seem like a handy guide you can
you do stuff where is it complicated no
that one's really caught you got to
rewire all this [ __ ] you need to plug
inside your bathroom and then you need a
separate entrance for the water to go up
like it's really complicated yeah
massage that's whole massage it is so
it's gotten to the point not even joking
that sometimes like hard when I was on
the road doing Travel Channel like right
I think right towards the tail-end is
when I wrote when I was first got him
was in Japan when I was doing Travel
Channel
that I go in with a bottle of water and
just school but would you wipe when you
did that yeah you not start dry before
the score first squirt oh I don't know I
enough pressure huh oh no it's like a
power wash it's got so much pressure it
can break the o-ring sometimes and it
turns into an enema I'm not even joking
I've definitely had a break the only
where it gets inside you and you're like
okay that's coming out like world but
it's warm so it feels good and then it's
just jump-starting the next one take
water yeah it's a lot like a water the
invention I want I want a water pick
inside my shower so when I'm showering I
just water pick my teacher ever heard of
ASMR yes so I've been meaning to watch
ASMR videos I have never and all of our
career online watched
ASMR videos I've been meaning to talk
about it forever but I thought that you
would enjoy to watch it out given your
affinity with the wonderful things of
the Internet
my daughter's got into ASMR really yeah
I think it's a lack of living a real
authentic life that you show like I need
something real like like yeah women
eating pasta like god it's like really
hate right I mean whispering and chewing
I mean there's a lot of interesting ones
here for example this is so this is kind
of par for the course here okay this is
a normal regular one this is the most
popular ace of our channel on YouTube
and by the way five million views bro
look at the views on her channel look at
this
oh she's 26 million 24 million 20
million what I am what do you think this
would be the same if she was ugly
absolutely not
it's exactly no no they it's a it's it I
was watching these before the show yeah
in turn was putting them together for me
and I'm like I feel like I'm cheating on
either right now yeah like this is so
weirdly intimate that I am uncomfortable
watching this being married that's why I
was surprised you saying your daughter
was watching because well there's
there's so many different varieties my
kids are the popular one my kids are
into people eating and like and like one
of the ASM ours that they do is those
slime videos where it's just more wrong
they just yeah but she's a slime my
daughters have a slime dude that's a new
generation of quicksand bro there will
be people going well have you seen slime
porn oh my god listen to her pop
actually this one this she's a it's not
old you probably have to say she's
killed this is the one that I was
watching I was like I feel like I'm
cheating on healer I know this she's
doing this you don't do this for me you
I get nervous from this song like put
that hand job away can I get some of
this ah would you remember when we were
kids when I was kid and you do this you
go and then you got behind someone and
it sound like a bee mmm why I thought
you quit you can't do it yourself the
right do it to someone else and right it
sound like a bee mmm it's not happening
the early day ASMR but watch this and
tell me how uncomfortable you are right
here let me crank it up everybody just
flick your eyes Tamar we're just really
lactation Oh
so they whispered crank the gain all the
way up so you hear every little thing
start you off with check our zero she's
gonna put lotion on her hands I need to
do a poll between people like me who
like this makes me the opposite of
relaxed
it's making me relaxed oddly enough I
listen to this in the car on night roof
I find it relaxing my father made me
actually but ela it makes me like
nervous and like if I put this on at
night I feel like a creep well not a
creep I'm not gonna I'm not gonna label
everyone that enjoys these videos but I
feel like I'm in an interrelation I feel
like I'm cheating on you I really do
it's like this whole roleplay things
like uh I mean and this is lotion I hope
she puts it on her lips really hugging
dry anyway at the engines I'm putting up
her ass it's a crazy twist but it's very
pornographic or welcome to him this is
so bizarre it's so weird
I just think that it's really a lot of
lonely guys out there this is akin to
like one of those futuristic movies she
just grabbed a bag of baby wipes she's
got whatever [ __ ] nearby man this is
just the idea that she knows this would
play well yeah she's a pro well honestly
I wonder who started it I do get it I do
have a sensation although they say it's
mostly in your scalp but I feel like
here oh if I watch a video where like a
dude falls like you ever see the videos
where the guy tries to dive off the
balcony and misses the pool lands on his
back my [ __ ] gets basically like goes
like goes wait
Wow you know what ask more videos I like
our our chiropractors mmm
listen to me like a role player just
type in ASMR actor and you can hear a
guy cracking guys back and for some
reason that makes me feel like like I
worked out or something let's watch they
some are chiropractor yeah it's just
type of ASMR chiropractor I guarantee
you just all these back crackers and
they just it's like they mic their chest
and then crack the guys back but is it
real real and I'm I could watch you guys
there's a lot on Instagram but I was
having a baby oh so a lot of them are
cute girls in like spandex to done hurt
this [ __ ] guy you telling me this guy
doesn't grab ass a little appropriate
inappropriately every now and then he
doesn't just brush a little too close on
that ass that's gonna be sound effects
no no no oh I guess they could do sadder
than anything right cross both or
anything oh my god
don't this is weird
chiropractic smite be all Oh
did you feel it alone I could feel a
little bit of a relief I gotta tell you
I think it's edited those sounds I don't
I don't know about that ela let's shrink
it up all the way because they do it ela
they always say some are channels do the
same thing where they turn the gain all
the way up and they're super high so you
can hear all these little things that
sounds real here we go oh I want that
done dude he was so angry after he
didn't move again
whoa hang on watch this move without so
funny back in like 1990 1997 I got it
what they called a DAT recorder and
you'd record it just did really crisp
audio they were expensive they were like
600 bucks
so it's basically an h4 and or like an
h6 one of the zoom recordings yeah but I
could record things and it would it was
it would sound more clear than it did in
the room and so I would me and my
friends got highs right when I moved to
New York to split him in 1998-99 and I
would record us all hanging out without
them knowing
and then I'd play it for them and they'd
listen to it us hanging out five minutes
ago in their headsets like this is
amazing because it was so Chris mm-hmm
so clear you were like I can't feel like
I'm in the room in you know like so I
guess I'm should have gone today it's
more back then I'd be oh yeah you havin
trouble either for sure a trillionaire
you know who listen who actually does
listen these every night who in the
intern Oh for real Ian are you there oh
yeah I'm here
so you are a consumer of ASMR right
yeah not every night but I watch a few
what does it do for you you what you
watch it to fall asleep while you watch
it like what do you get out of it it is
relaxing it's kind of calming it's like
instead of just putting a show on TV to
fall asleep to I have someone whisper in
my ear you like the cute girls right you
those are the ones you picked out like
the cute popular girls I I just searched
ASMR and those are always the top ones
that come out so not not enough right I
find the alternative do you ever feel
seduced by these girls do you ever feel
like you're I mean it is quite intimate
do you feel that intimacy oh well we're
all in love right yeah girls yeah yeah
I've felt like I've formed relationships
with people that I follow online
unhealthy way a lot of like a lot of
them I follow them and I get so into
their lives and then I'll be like on the
Instagram and I'm like do you ever watch
it with guys do you feel I've seen one
or two I've been auto rolled into a guy
and do you feel like gay at all when
that happens I mean not to like put it
you know bluntly but I feel like I feel
intimate you you get with your get with
your boys and have them whisper in your
ear you know it's fun there's some I
would like to take air smarter the next
level do like black eyed a movie theater
ASMR where you're you can hear the movie
theater and everything we use here the
black guys just talking like commands
ain't gonna happen
he's a whisper they have much a
role-playing stuff for real
here's one guy that super popular I just
think he's got a whole thing going this
isn't real human was a robot name is
Tony bamboo that's not a real name have
you watched Tony Benn Boni and I have
not doing your makeup today do you feel
relaxed by this one do you feel the same
way can I tell you I really do in a way
like I feel like he's gonna
physiologist the way he introduced
himself I was like you I'm gonna be
putting you under today just want me to
start running backwards from so it's
just whispering yeah I can't stand like
the whole yeah wait wait wait let's
compounds like you look like a [ __ ]
robot no one ever tells you that you
remind me of Max Headroom but then so
then we get really weird okay now let's
go down the hole the rabbit hole so
here's one that's very popular [ __ ]
popular girl new stepsister roleplay so
it's both so she like humiliates you
very cute girl obviously that's how it
works I'm learning my humiliation
relaxes you
watch this Oh
let's be clear we are not friends and do
not want to be associated with you okay
what do you think about that imagine
trying to fall asleep to this [ __ ] right
dude I want I need to go deeper in this
by the way I will just be doing this on
open tabs next week this is [ __ ]
genius but like it's I just I just my
god we have like okay when I said
blackout a movie theater do they they
really do this but I don't know if black
I know that would be such a layer just
to see a black I'd be like I just loved
the idea of someone like Ian laying in
bed at night who usually this is the
ASMR relaxed and you just got this a
girl like bitching at you and your ear
it's like you're relaxing and she's also
like humiliating and bitching at you can
we just give it up to Gwen jizz for that
our name grunge's Oh Gwen quiz 1g1 quiz
dude she's got a tip jar just to
straight a PayPal link shut up oh I pay
her I give her some glute cuz let me
tell you something she got 17 minutes
and 59 seconds of improv about being a
[ __ ] lesson I'm Kerri you kidding me
yeah she is drawing this from a real
place this is a real thing what could
you talk about in the ASMR for 20
minutes yeah without having to go to a
script well mean bipolar girl Oh mean
popular I got one bipolar girl let's see
how this escalates let's get to the end
oh she's like oh you can kill time by
just filing your nails but she's combing
your hair oh my god wait you think she's
combing your sister's hair the new
sister's hair your hair you're right you
picked up on that
yeah I could totally get into this this
[ __ ] has never brought makeup so anyway
it gets much weirder I mean this is just
for the surface this is insane what's
going on here while I'm in notes on here
come on get out get the [ __ ] out of here
now I closed it I wanted I want to think
of mine and some are role-playing that I
could get in so what would that be um
okay well it's got to be something
people connect to right it can't just be
something that you're into but it's got
to be something people connect to that
you can do for 20 minutes straight
without looking at a script so shoenice
you know sure nice oh he's a legend he
eats cases alcohol so he may I've heard
of him
hey ASMR eating chips video okay he just
eats chips all right thank you I'm gonna
do an answer more of drinking Tito's and
soda mmm I'm gonna do these I'm not even
joking I'm doing I don't want to do one
role play I'm trying to think of like oh
my my Tito's okay mine would be talking
to a stewardess on the flight like going
and she's cutting me off but I'm trying
to get myself
[Laughter]
he's a doctor he's trying to give me
pills and I'm afraid of flying that is
that is insane I've been wanting to do
ASMR for a long time too but
I haven't done it it's just so fine so
fertile it's just like I feel like this
is gonna sound almost sociopathic I feel
like it's something you just got to do a
lot of the March oh I think it's I I
thought you said challenge and I think
channel I like the pressure a some more
challenge where people as much as me
getting characters me and do ASMR for 20
minutes as Bert in different scenarios
Jesus I like that Christ you're calling
it out now guys the Bert Kreischer ASMR
ones me trying to get them to open the
door at McDonald's over here what you
know this is the deep web of apparently
relaxing somehow I'm sorry gave me
anxiety Buckland John Rowe alright so
for those who can't see I don't know how
to describe him creepy mask it's a bird
mask but it's like a it's like a
steampunk bird mask creepy [ __ ] and he's
got potions all on a top hat I was
trying to think how to describe those
potions with white gloves on and a
bowtie looks like a cedar at a nice
restaurant with a leather white leather
steampunk mask right thank you that was
very well described thank you i watch
this one a lot there's that but then
there's there's ones that are really
popular ASMR kidnapping roleplay and
this one features a dude which is a band
like Alex Jones they banned Alex Jones
and they've got ASMR kidnap rope I mean
it kind of like a rape fantasy like this
is the one that the women watch if I'm
being Frank
400,000 views into that there's a guy in
our back with the beer he's holding a
knife he's grabbing ameralik is
caressing your face yo flag his video
this guy's black this is their so he got
into this wait I can never see me and
girl pics on new sister I can't even
understand put on a mask and act like a
lunatic one of the one of the comments
though like do you like ratios really
good is it yeah he's only gotten 214
dislikes I mind it forever very good
acting I don't know I don't know if it's
great acting funny story brilliant so
well not out and about as realistic guys
again so are people just isn't really a
lot of experience with each other I
don't know man
it's a smart baby it's a whole brave new
world I like that it's all done
whispering yeah almost like like it like
takes out the acting part of it and just
like oh just whispered halt I feel like
there's gotta be people who hate
whispering right it doesn't bother me I
know you got a fan of the whisper you
don't like whispering no and you don't
like them that I totally get you know
one time I was with a I was dating a
girl in college and I thought things
were going really well she was I was I
was into it and I thought she was really
into it too it was going great and I'm
hanging out in her dorm room this is
freshman year we're in the dorms and
we're hanging out just the two of us and
I just and I never do this I don't know
why I did but I just go like that and
she [ __ ] snapped and like never
talked to me again why did you if he
goes excuse me can you please never do
that again and I was like whoa yeah I
want to that again horse the diver did
and I so that I know you don't like it
but not and I was that ik what I was
wanting to create my crazy for you had
interactions involving insane like I
thought it was going great
like I thought we are we were really
hitting it off all it took was one of
these my wife it's pulling her PO
detail if you pull my wife's ponytail
like to a irrational place here's the
kicker you ready
her dad pulls her ponytail all the time
oh I shouldn't say [ __ ] world and I
went to analyze I while we were in
Alabama and her dad came up said what's
up frog and full ponytail and she went
hello daddy and then I went up I went up
like a minute later I was like what's up
frog don't ever [ __ ] do that again he
just did the same thing she goes it's
very different very different no way
okay Wow you do not pull my wife's
ponytail have you got have you tried to
understand that no I think that she
wasn't allowed to vote I mean yeah my
dad's not watching this I don't think
she was allowed to have a voice with her
dad and I think that yeah because she
was afraid he'd leave because we her mom
bailed on her I think she was it wasn't
right and she didn't like it but she
couldn't vocalize that and then when she
feel safe with you she vocalizes it like
what's that a compliment really yeah
when we all go to dinner I wanted to
just power my wife her ponytail and see
if she vocalizes it to you and then I'll
just do it like right after you can see
her lose urge so your so when we go out
to dinner you're inviting me to pull
your wife's just pawn it I just go
what's up frog what's up frog I think
she's she's slow yeah she's got a lot
slower the older she's got recently I
was amazed to find out that you
completed a travel yeah that was a
me-too moment he just went you don't
look you look like I mean not totally in
shape right not not totally in shape no
I'm definitely out of shape but like you
also on one hand did a triathlon yeah so
can you be both things I think so I
think I think I am the most in shape out
of shape guy in the world like Iran it
started with
I started with Iran in the LA Marathon
with no training at all how many miles
was that 26 points and you
random how did you place not I mean good
I ran it five hours and 33 minutes so
but I'm not like great like average is
that about average no I think Irish is
like probably four four hours and 30
minutes or so you were you were almost
untrained no training how I can't I can
barely run around the block dude
alright well what happened was I can't
run around the block we did that sober
October challenge me Rogan and re and we
finished it and we were our you know I
felt brave I had a little bravado
because I'd just not drank her done
drugs for a month and so I'm like I can
do anything and then we all get drunk on
Joe's podcast and I said very
confidently
I could definitely run a marathon with
no training and everyone Joe
in all fairness Joe was the voice of
reason and he was like I think he could
do it I think wasn't hurt but I don't
think you could do it under five hours I
go I could do it under five hours and
Ari was like oh you couldn't beat my dad
Dory's dad is a Holocaust survivor and
80 years old and he had done it like six
hours
well I could definitely beat your dad
he's a tre but how did you know that you
could do that because like I said I'm I
cannot run around the block I didn't do
you run like okay I run like a like a
regular person would I'm not like a you
go for runs I try to do it often but
like three miles is long how are you if
you're running three miles regularly how
are you still so in shape I won't drink
a lot I think I drink a lot is what the
number one thing and so but so then I
said I could do it so I signed up the LA
Marathon no training like other than
regular it's just like I didn't do a
parent on plan
I just basically jogged whenever I feel
like jogging I didn't jog when I didn't
want to jog I drank the night before
showed up no training and I was bragging
about it I was like in line on Instagram
stories going you trained for this I was
like not me and then I ran and I just
jogged the whole way at 22 miles my
calves seized up my quads seized auto
Mike and the woman in front of me [ __ ]
her pants and I was like oh I saw her
and it she was like an executive she
liked it and it was like a band-aid one
down one leg and up one cheek and
everyone sort of falling off like
zombies
this is why you dream bro and then I
finished it and so then and so then
men's house came to me and they were
like you can find the trailer if you
want to watch the trailers on my
Instagram you see the trailer of this
men's health came to me and they're like
they're like very candidly there are
inspirational people online like that
are like like like Cameron Haynes and
David Goggins and and Jaco will Nick and
and Peter attea all these guys are like
ultra marathon swimmers Navy SEALs ultra
marathon runners
you know these funds these guys are just
amazing individuals and they are
inspiring to me I'm inspired by every
single one of them I watch them and I
listen to them and I go I think they're
saying is when I don't want to do stuff
and they're like but I think a lot of
people see those and go oh I'll never be
able to do that and then they go and
then we see you do it and you're like
accessible to the average guy so Men's
Health is like we want to follow you do
another marathon I'm like I'm never
doing another marathon if I'm done that
was the dumbest thing I ever did and
they're like what do you want to do I
was like a car boys want to do a
triathlon and they're like we'll get
your triathlon coach we'll get you a
nutritionist get you everything you
prepared so I well kind I rode my bike
once I bought a really nice bike by rote
at once make sure I knew how to work the
gears I ran on treadmills I didn't
really run in the open road too much and
then I just and then I did the swim I
slowly think I did was swimming by
anyone spend that much because like I
mean technically because I'm my marathon
my triathlon coach saw me swim once he's
like you're a swimmer you'll be fine
you're like an elite athlete duh can
someone please isolate that audio I
swear to god dude if you came up to I've
run a marathon at wrathful and a half
marathon at a Spartan Race and I've been
lost for say oh this guy [ __ ] psycho
I don't know what he's he's just a
pathological liar oh no I wouldn't even
believe it yeah it's all on Instagram
how I did it I have seen it here's what
he raised he is that unbelievable part
of me was like heartless so to finish
the triathlon story there were they were
they were like my triathlon coach was
like alright we're ballparking it like
day up he's like if you can if you can
do the triathlon in an hour of 45
minutes he's like that's why I think
your goal should be doing an hour and 45
but then I got out there and I got
competitive
I almost died I got into the swim and I
was like in fourth place and I'm like
I'm like yeah and I'm like what are
these guys idiots and then I and then
all of a sudden this Chinese guy jumped
on my back and sunk me and I breathes in
water and then everyone started climbing
over over top he's like I'm [ __ ]
moshpit it's got a freakin a hundred
feet of water four hundred yards from
the my back like this for like [ __ ]
they're just selling the zone there it's
a competition they're not so great this
is there something at stake with it was
trying to get you out of the way yeah no
yeah basically you're in their way and
they just climb all over you
is it is there a prize no prize no
rotten sedative just come up additive
love for the game yeah and so I finished
I got out of the water in like eight ten
minutes I think eight minutes I don't
know because I didn't stop my watch at
the right moment I stopped to watch
smoked after you're near driving I did
but then I got my [ __ ] together trust me
there was a moment where almost waved a
lifeguard like I know they're all right
there and you could just be like just do
a hold on your board for me why don't
you would like like just stuck just give
me the sign they were there were kids
there were children just sitting on
board you have to be rescued by some
child that's not happening so I got on
my back and I BAC battled like back swam
for a second and then I flipped over
finish the swim in like ten minutes
eight minutes ten minutes got on the
bike and I was like oh I'm smoking dudes
but then I go to the up hill and they
all just pass me I was like gassed out
from falling out of his lock-up Hill
dude and I'm so impressed I can do the
triathlon in an hour twenty-one instead
of an hour forty-five and they were like
what anyway the big [ __ ] you're not let
a guy go okay baseball but here's the
thing the position
catcher left field yeah monster hitter
I know I've always by the third but not
like I mean I guess I was bigger than
everyone else usually but ya know yeah I
mean got recruited to go to college and
then went to Florida State to walk on
okay and then went to one practice and
was like this is not for me look catch
bullpens I walked I'm not even joking I
walked off that field out the left field
fence went straight over to my dorm
Sally hall room one
eleven went in Chile Willie Paul Pisa
Chandler Perry were all in the room just
getting high we used to this thing
called time-traveling where we'd black
out all the windows play Pink Floyd and
lay on the ground smoke weed and just
time travel and I was like I'm done
baseball I'm gonna party professionally
and I listened to Pink Floyd just and
but here's the thing that I believe
right
Casey and I stat very interesting guy
very polarizing sometimes as a fan he
could be polarizing I know you worked
with him and you're friends with him but
like yeah I'm a fan of his for years now
yeah um he said something that just
stuck with me like stuck so heavy with
me he was someone was asking him about
snapchat and he goes I to snap staff the
way I do everything tell the story tell
a story just to have a beginning middle
and an end and I went and it I didn't
understand snapchat at the time and I
was like oh okay so when Instagram
stories came out and that was more
accessible for me and my fan base I
think I went what I'll do is I'll find
ways to tell a story so I'll do a half
marathon I'll do a Spartan Race I'll do
a triathlon I'll do a marathon I'll go
to Paris I'll go to taking on tour I'm
doing a theater tour come follow my
story and then have a beginning middle
and end like you find me and I that is
what how I use Instagram stories and so
someone like a triathlon
I find that fun I mean my interaction
was like through the roof that day and
then people are like I'm going in and
like going into American Airlines to
check in for my flight and the girl the
lady took a man's life hey how was the
travel I love your stories that's a yeah
so I think that is how I use Instagram
and then I use the feed part for like
that one big promo I shoot or you know
yeah so but but so I'm gonna I'm going
to Paris next week just on a lark so I
was like [ __ ] it a lark
yeah just like a global adventure yeah I
was like we got a special to play lark
and I have it's just like you know win
spontaneous I did I had a weekend off
and I was like and I was like I was like
I'm gonna probably be doing press and I
was like in New York and then part of me
is like you know what I'm just gonna
that you're feeling adventurous no no
and I'll put it on my stories and then
people can follow me in Paris and eat my
way through Paris and drink my way into
the night and then find out where I stay
and you know I was like [ __ ] it why not
you know yeah that's going across not as
a rule santa cruz's it's my favorite
place we we lived there together now do
you guys turn off your professional life
when you go do this last time we were
there we were shooting a vlog and it's
like yeah it's always kind of like you
have busy with that that's why I stopped
doing mind occupied with like where's
that good shot coming yeah you know
that's why it's good is what I think
about Casey nice that is like well he
stopped doing his vlog I was like thank
God because he seems like he has a
really cool life but I know that he's
not getting to taste it
yeah it's when he's getting in the
helicopter he's also thinking of his
exterior shot is his entry song this
drone shot he's got all the angles
[ __ ] up yeah I mean that we've gone
through that and that's why we pretty
much stopped making videos on our main
channel and really I mean we don't we
haven't posted there in a long time and
we just kind of one day we're like we
can't not sustain this anymore it's too
hard my daughter you'll hear my daughter
say stuff like everything doesn't need
to go on Instagram dad and you're just
like yeah but you well it's uh it's
about your relationship with it if you
if it doesn't bother you if you're
excited and it's fun for you that's then
that's wholesome and good yeah but for
us and I'm sure for Casey to where it's
like it feels bad and you're aware that
it feels bad and you don't want to be
doing it you're anxious and you're
stressed all the time that's when it's
bad but if you enjoy it yeah thank god
bless I loved I loved when you guys did
that like cochere or was it called when
you switch switch proper what's called
flip flop when you guys do both do
something for each other's channel o
collab cool we did it we did it
like part of me was like I wish someone
else had a camera I wanted to see that
points that you did I want to see what
you guys didn't show
you know what I mean like fascinating
part for me that's what I love about
podcasts it's like yeah you put your
armor down and you just share sometimes
stuff you don't like from wiping you
know I know because those videos are so
edited yeah you know from two hours it
could go down to 10 minutes that's of
course every time yeah and that's the
Kurt and that's why I love doing the
show live - because it's like no
take-backs dude you know it's all out
there dude it makes it hold you
accountable here's what I also love
about a podcast and I've said this a
number of times is that if you're
watching this and listening and you hear
something you're offended by this is an
extension of social media share what
offends you with the person creating it
and explain to them why and help change
their mind as opposed to like
tattletaling like Jeff said some [ __ ]
my legit across the board mm-hmm and my
fans lawyers be like bro that that was
like one hour 33 seconds 22 like check
what you gotta really think that it's I
know that everyone's laughing in the
room but it's not funny and you're like
oh okay so I mean I've I dude I was at
the beginning of podcasting when you
could go out and say [ __ ] and ruin
friendships didn't even know you were
doing it you were just like like what
like how would that happen me there's
this guy there's this comedian all say
his name so I want to like put him on
blast but he kind of like took a story
from me and what does that mean like
like a bit I he was telling a story and
he was a when he was telling the story
he was saying that it happened to me he
was telling one stage name it having a
bird happened to play comedy and then
one day Tom Segura we were all three
friends Tom called me at me as I came in
just so you know he's saying it happen
to him now and he never really talked to
me about that he just started doing it
and thinking and you guys were close
friends we were pretty close so that's
pretty taboo right I mean they're really
taboo yeah and I tried to have
conversation with them and it was that a
bit you wanted to use actually no that's
what's a problematic about it but the
problem was I didn't I almost really
didn't want the bit out there yeah
because it was it's a great story but
it's part of me was like you know what
the person that's involved in the story
they may not remember that it happened
to me they definitely all know it didn't
happen to you but then when it comes
back to me he's gonna be like what and
I'm gonna
look like an [ __ ] so I'd rather and
if I had this to do decide to tell it I
want to tell it on my timeline I want to
be the one to be able to tell it yeah I
want to meet the guy that it happened
with and say again and go hey man this
story happened yeah and this and it's a
great story I want to tell you the story
about I'd like to tell it on stage I
need your blessing that's how I go about
it yeah but this other guy just started
saying it happened to him and then and
then I went on Joe's podcasts and was
like and Joe just asked me about it and
this is like just probably like seven
years ago eight years ago and I just I
just told him like the way we're talking
right now and yeah like and do I was
unaware of how many people were
listening right and all of a sudden and
then it started a huge fight between me
and the guy and then the guy just was
like [ __ ] you don my friend and I was
like it was just really confusing and I
haven't spoke to the guy since yeah yeah
yeah so so that but the I did that into
a couple people like I would just get
drunk on a podcast that's a be honest
dude that's the killer I used to get I
used to drink and I pretty much stopped
just because it's like when you're live
you want to make sure yeah you're saying
what you mean right yeah but I see I'm
drunk so much that I'm really I'm a bad
job I might flip tables when I'm dry
remember that may have been the last
time I drank real no no there were a
couple a couple in between all right I'm
pretty cool being drunk and I'm still
biting my tongue if I if I know it's
gonna hurt somebody but if it's about me
or like my thoughts I'll just share them
and then I'll and if I if they're messed
up then I'll either defend them or a go
yeah you're right I'm wrong I'm totally
wrong [ __ ] up sure you know but I
drink a lot what did the guy say what
how did he uh how did he come to terms
with having so I stole your bit he said
the last thing he said to me was you are
a garbage human being piece of [ __ ] and
you have no friends and you'll realize
in a year that you'll have a I was the
only friend you ever had and you have no
friends
and he's like lose my number I don't
ever want to speak to you again you're
dead to me
mom I was like and by the way I like it
it was so confusing at the time because
I thought I thought we were okay like I
thought we were gonna figure this out
like I thought we could figure all of
this out and everyone was gonna be fine
and he just said that and then deploy at
that point it was better it was
Christmas Eve and I liked him and I went
on a hike up to the mountains with my
daughters and to the Hollywood sign and
I got up there and I thought I'm putting
so much energy in trying to fix this
when the guy doesn't want to fix it and
to be honest with you I go in and clear
conscience I didn't do anything wrong
sure like I was like I didn't do
anything wrong and I was like I gotta
let this go this is Christmas Eve and I
let it go that day and I said my wife
said to me let it go right now
never don't talk to that about this for
there used to be I'll tell you there's a
funny word we used to use to about not
talking about it she's like let it go
now and just let it go and you can't be
friends with me you never talk to him
again just he's out of your life that's
what it is that's what he wants that's
what you want that's what you need then
do it and I did just haven't spoken to a
minute and that's good advice that's
wise it's hard to let go people go out
of your life yeah it's a breakup with a
friend and be like hey man I we're not
having fun anymore and comes to a dude
it sounds so weird I've broken up with
dudes before my buddy broken up with
guys before well there's been one when
you know I guess I don't know was there
a big breakup I don't know lay it on the
air did I have a big male breakup that I
don't remember yeah my buddy Eddie now
I'm really interested we've broken up a
number of times and then he's also
broken up with my buddy Chris and and so
I remember one time going to Atlanta and
being like hey Chris we should all hang
out he's like Oh Eddie and I are on a
break but I am intrigued and I don't
want to bring it up I'm just asking as
I'm intrigued but did he ever come to
terms like he understood like yes that
was your story and I stole it yes he's
kind of he's definitely come to terms
with it did he ever apologize me like I
should have done that but you shouldn't
have done that
like we've never spoken since I we've
weird at a time and shared a manager and
we and a friend
and that manager tried to negotiate like
almost like a getting back together and
but I had said you know when that thing
went down I was like I can't I don't I'm
done I'm done done and then I grew into
like a different man than I am today and
I don't think I could ever go back to
the guy that he knew like I don't know
but that would even work but I see him
on Twitter and Instagram so every now
and then he seems like he's doing I'll
say all I'll say is and I don't know but
he seems like he's doing very well he
seems like he's very happy I feel like
he's gone through a lot but I feel like
he's found peace in his life I got some
on his entry I went flip through his
Instagram the other day and I was like
dude I'm like I'm almost happy for him
like he seems like he's don't know so
much of a better place than I ever knew
him to be and so and by the way it's I
was gonna ask did it affect his career
does I think a little bit I think a
little bit but I think I think that was
just part of it I think some other stuff
happened with him where he like I think
just life got chaotic for him for a
second and he was so focused on
everything else that he didn't have time
to focus on his career and then but he's
doing fine
I mean he's you know he's working
everyone's working yeah I've I've
definitely said and done [ __ ] on this
podcast that has haunted me on to me
dude when when we did I mean this is
real like not me I'll tell I don't care
I'll tell it [ __ ] anything anyone
haha the biggest missed the biggest
mistake I ever made in my life like and
I and it wasn't a mistake it wasn't a
mistake it was the right thing to do but
when we did the podcast where me Ari and
Tom decided to do sober October they
asked me how much I drank and I sat
there for a second and I thought I was I
remember where I was sitting I remember
how I felt I remember where I looked
because they were sitting in a certain
way and I looked at Tom who I knew would
be the most empathetic I thought I
thought if you lie you're always gonna
be lying just tell the truth and I told
him how many TT toes and so does I have
in a day and I looked - Tom knowing Joe
wasn't in like like the answer and Tom
looked at me like how much
I got a knight like you gonna bring one
on stage you have another one and a
couple more after that and then like I
whatever the answer I don't even know
what the answer is anymore
I don't know right but it was like it
was a lot it was a lot yeah
and I remember Tom's like body energy
changed and he was like wait hold on and
I went in bed that night I got in bed
that night and I was like bro you should
have never shown them the man behind the
curtain like I was like why would you
ever be honest since that day have did
was that did you know that people were
gonna react that way like sup I didn't
did you think that was somewhat normal
amount to be drinking it it just it just
got there have you scaled back snow yeah
we did sub rocktober right I didn't
drink for a month and then I went on a
tear in November and obviously but then
what happened is I started getting ready
for my special so I shot it in February
and then I was like the biggest this is
gonna sound so [ __ ] silly the biggest
thing I learned in in after sober
October was that I can go to sleep sober
like I don't need like put myself to
sleep I could just go lay in a bed and
go this will happen here we go
there we go you had this every night I
had to have a drink I'd have a drink to
go to bed I die like that it was the way
I wrapped up my night all right guys
let's have dinner honey went open a
bottle wine sure bottle of wine split a
bottle of wine
she'd have a glass I'd finish the rest
and then I'm making cocktails sit down
watch TV make another cocktail she go to
bed one more cocktail [ __ ] its cigar on
a one-hitter outside like that just and
Evers every I was every night and then
do you ever concern that you were
growing an addiction no I was way past
that like her wasn't worried about the
idea I was like I was like we are where
we are this is what I do for a living
this is who I am a fly I party but then
you quit cold-turkey for a whole month
yeah well yeah and everyone was like
you're gonna have a stroke I was like
it's dangerous if you're addicted no
book I wasn't addicted apparently yeah
if you do it but you got to do it I mean
I'm not look I mean I've seen
documentaries of alcohol addicts it's a
special kind like these guys drink yeah
whole bottles it's very do more than
that once again I'm not a doctor so
anyone listening do not listen to what
I'm telling you
just because it worked for me do not you
have a freak body that you don't run
triathlons and drink today what happened
is so we did so by October and also
shoenice
you're like a successful shoe nice you
don't know that means no I do like you
have an incredible body you endure yeah
can you achieve yeah
despite your efforts to just destroy
your own body I take that as a
compliment but yeah I didn't I didn't I
just quit drinking and then there was no
like I felt no withdrawals I felt no
really bounce back I just was like I
don't know Apple your blood and like I
don't know like need to drink I just was
like I was like was it cool and then
when I started drinking I only started
because we were no Orleans and I was
with Arie he's like let's get [ __ ]
drunk
you know where I was like cool and we've
got a buzz again and and I drank a
little bit but then in November I just
got the offer or like end of October I
got the offer for Netflix and I was like
okay now I gotta get to work and so I
just scaled back my drinking to like you
know if I wanted to party I could party
but I had to focus on the special right
didn't drink leading up to the special
did a special and the LA Marathon was
around the corner didn't drink going
into that and then and then like partied
you know but then was like oh triathlons
coming up not drinking like I'm not
drinking right now but but but that's
what's scary is I don't like want to
tell people like I'm not drinking like
that's not me I drink if I want to drink
like if I wanted to drink like tonight
I'm taking a car service down to Irvine
and taking it back and in my head I'm
like alright shut drink tonight I don't
have to drive I was like I got two shows
I wouldn't mind a cocktail on like a
late show when I start the machine story
and then I was like maybe I'll text my
friend and see if we go for a bike ride
tomorrow if we go for a bike ride I
won't drink I'm definitely doing it
Saturday night cuz like we're taking a
party bus down to Irvine all our friends
are on it and I'm gonna I'm gonna party
on that I'm gonna party back we're doing
a screening of my special at my friend's
house got a big screening room going
party is fun I'm doing only Monday so I
won't party like I'll probably scale
back early Monday night but I'm but I
got on a red-eye to New York I'm
partying
I just look at where they drink and I go
all right we got an okay good I wish I
wish I enjoyed I wish I enjoyed drinking
I really do
okay don't work I don't enjoy weed
either yeah you see people smoking and
they seem to enjoy it so much and when I
smoke all that happens to me they say
they know it happy hungry sleepy that's
all happens what happens to me it
[ __ ] paranoid yeah depressed blood
necessar panic attack II oh and it
always makes people together too and
then people will be like your best
friend we talked together and and when
you say no it's like such a
disappointment and don't ya alright hey
you want to blaze my best friend right
it would be great if they had fake weed
you just did it you know grow anything
but you had that moment of connection
like I like I like a nice one-hitter of
stuff that I've green lit like where I
go to my own dispensary and I go here's
what I'm looking for I like that but I
only like one hit and then what I do now
I'm probably more of is I'll take I'll
have a drink and then I'll take a
one-hitter and then I'm good like I can
really sell one Oh you mix and match no
just just one hit of weeds yeah that is
what I enjoyed the most when I'm John
takes the edge off you see I don't get
it
and all the reason it's collar bowls
because you're just so drunk that you
can't even oh yeah I even edibles in my
mancave one time I there were a little
goldfish right so I'm sitting there I'm
hanging out I'm drinking and I was like
[ __ ] it I'm not I'm not mining that
buzzed I was like I got these edibles
you know what I'm gonna watch a cool
movie and I eat the edibles I'm barely
shrinking I'm like they're gonna put me
to sleep and all of a sudden I feel my
butthole meld into the couch and I'm
like okay something's going on call my
sisters I go hey how many of those
goldfish should I have had they're like
one can I go handful Oh buckle up big
boy
and I don't work I was like I was like
whiskey you got a beat up I wish I could
do that oh not good
late I love in bed not forgetting how to
breathe the joy of smoking weed I don't
chase I wish that I had something to
wash I feel like it on body hobbies like
I don't enjoy drugs now what being
depressed is that's what I want herself
I say I don't enjoy anything am I
depressed and the answer is probably yes
dude yes you idiot you've been depressed
see it's different
she worked out or bad by the way this is
super meta but we're battling with
something our parents never had to
battle our parents never got to follow
their dreams so when they had a job at
an insurance company or my dad was a
lawyer he then got off work was like I
hate that now I'm gonna do what I love
see I only do what I love so like I so
like I'm like I had my therapist was
like you need a hobby I said I have a
hobby of shooting a vlog and he does
that's not a hobby yes I will no editing
videos is the ha because no I go writing
jokes he's like that's not right I was
like I'm like making likes writing
scripts is like no do nothing
work-related yeah and so I took up
leather working but making leather like
I'm sick but wallets and stuff and then
in the middle of doing I'm like I could
sell these are my show but you know when
I had a desk job for five years before
we really successful here in Israel yeah
five [ __ ] years like marketing and
like I had the week the work week sucked
I [ __ ] hated every second of it when
you those weekends on those night homes
you see I'm closing my eyes cuz I'm
cherishing it so much worse bliss bliss
dude I said to someone and this is it by
the way this is hashtag first world
problems I said to someone I would love
to have a job where I built
and then I could just leave my work
there until I bet you would love to
build fences come home and be like who
was swimming and pull out Instagram be
like we're getting in the pool I got two
shows in Irvine I think it's like 30
love at the valachia
like I would love to do that but yeah
then you go that guy building fences
yeah he's like dude I got a podcast it's
a pot it's a passion project it's my
hobby and you're like oh that's my job
it's I remember what I remember is those
great weekends but but what I forget so
easily is sitting eight hours so lessly
and feeling the minutes of your life
take away down the drain your finite
energy your creative energy the essence
of who you are going down the drain
every [ __ ] minute I just sit there
and I go I am wasting want me to bring
something original I'm just gonna do you
know I feel like dude I cannot like I
wouldn't mind doing a multicam where
it's like Bert walks in they're like and
they're like dad's home and you hear the
whole studio Hans but I couldn't I okay
I don't think I could be you have long
days on set because I've never been on
set like to that degree you just sit
there like you just sit there sit there
I mean I guess like if you're someone
creative like Dave's probably probably
write a script but like you multitask
you multitask I guess I don't multitask
I just browse Twitter and I'm like I'm
like dude HEIs bothering you from did
Twitter because my eyes like I you know
when I have morning we just literally
said that right now yeah like - by the
way does that bother you because I
[ __ ] hate that I do that like I'll
wake up at 8:00 and I'll get outta bed
at 10:00 and I'm like what is wrong with
you are sick bro
an hour I hate I give it an hour the
other day my wife cuz you did that for
an hour
yeah and the worst part is like after 10
minutes you've seen everything
everything and then and by the way I
would love to switch phones and see what
your
discovery page looks like because mine
is I say no no I don't think you have
thanked votes and guys hitting golf
balls well here let me show you here
let's godiscover I just have a trench
for you oh good on the cane you don't
see a John McCain no I see two hundred
thousand tweets I see a woman on a
motorcycle
I'm bobber where are you an Instagram or
Twitter Instagram Oh No instagrams weird
man they they they get weird definitely
based on what kind of embarrassed to
show you anything with a cop getting
this is a cop getting hit by a car I
watch a lot of meat like I'm obsessed
with these Turkish chefs they like cook
crazy meat and like barbecue [ __ ] really
in the barbecuing and cooking and
there's like all these Turkish meat guys
dude I have golfers all over my page I
don't even really golf like Ivan I mean
I can golf I golf but like I'm not go
for like I said it's some of those like
I said when we were talking about doing
promo for the special I was like I'm
gonna do a golf video and they're like
why I don't know they seem to be all
over the place golf is so popular right
now boats I get a lot of boats like just
dudes and boats I got the shoot the the
faster land challenge after them yeah
like it's it's I think it's just a black
Instagram doing it but they go man all
these [ __ ] be like it's a it's
a shot of the ground like this like this
is the ground this is the phone the
phones on the ground right you don't see
the person's face you see their foot
stepping a shot and then they start
tying their shoes like man all these
[ __ ] head they'd be faster than
me
ain't nobody passes the mission and
they're tying their shoe and as soon as
their shoes tires are like back and they
take off running away from the camera
that's typing running check I'm not in
the program here the know I'm all over
black Instagram I look that's my I think
I might just be black employ what is it
fall running challenge I am NOT oh this
is from 2016
no they're brand new I think it's
running running man
nope well don't let me see if I can
running challenge Instagram this is
niche man you're in deep on this [ __ ] I
met Jesus and Miro through black Twitter
is that another app that no this is
running challenge challenge they're all
running challenge all right well I care
oh you know what you know what let me go
on instagram itself look
Takashi 6:9 did one of them oh I think
Takashi six nine might have started it
oh [ __ ] I don't know how to Bret I I
don't know how to watch it so everyone
could hear you in goddamnit
so don't make me back so back on the way
back in the day deism arrow were all
about black Twitter right and I love
black Twitter like it was my favorite
and they'd have like the one that I got
involved with was v-day gifts for the
hood hashtag and it was all I thought I
mean like I'm not I'm not saying I'm
progressive I'm just a regular dude but
like I found it to be a tad bit like
almost a little racist cuz they were
just it was like the worst things about
the hood they were saying that's what
you should get for your girl for
Valentine's Day they're like how about a
mattress how buy it behind the hood cuz
she can jump on it like I was like huh
they're like get her a click-clack you
know she needs one she got seven but get
her not a baby like those were all the
things and I was like and so then as a
joke I went on and I wrote bigots
through the hood and I was like anything
Dungeons and Dragons son and this guy
these guys were like no man the same for
you and I was like what well they're
like we don't play Dungeons and Dragons
like they thought I was being serious
and I was like okay okay I just write in
the same hashtag I'm replying to all of
them my god okay I'm sorry
I go how about a classy pen and they're
like no brah we don't we don't [ __ ] with
classy pens and they're like and they're
like everyone's coming at me and then I
was like alright how about a bottle of
champagne but spray it all over like a
ho and they're like that's more like it
like and I got we got some running
challenge yeah we got it
here we go good can you do that under
your profile
come on this I gotta tell you Windows
has been [ __ ] me for so long with
this internet explorer [ __ ] like you
know nobody wants to use a [ __ ]
I have adblock installed I'm doing a
live show for a reason
I don't want pop-ups while I'm doing a
live show I have sponsors for Christ's
sake
there's like good money for those
sponsorships and now I've got curiosity
stream plus Sprint getting free
advertisement I don't think so
so we just go away I closed it now I
gotta open it on Chrome on a separate
menu but I feel like I've changed it so
many times to preference chrome instead
of Internet Explorer I was at the
airport the day Joshi 6:9 got jumped
like you got no fight at the he had an
alibi I guess he did this video and then
people are now copying that video that's
running I ologist started as Takashi 6-9
though he's goofing around he's a funny
guy he's trolling that's a lot I hate
when people like underestimate me like
how fast I am before one video like that
was one video like fast they're saying
slow or some [ __ ] and fastest [ __ ]
yeah yeah he's got 6/9 at all that
tattooed all over him that's dedication
man yeah making it work there's only one
way to do it this way
I saw him got beat he got beat up at the
airport and then they're not beat up by
I mean he got beat up but and then I was
in line behind them in security oh you
were there
oh I was there I guess some Crips I was
like relate was gang-related
no Bloods maybe I guess he has people
Bloods um he I have a joke inside my
head
he should have called himself
sickle-cell he's got beef with blood
really good beep of blood and so they
were at the airport and they followed
him to the airport I guess and then they
got out and I started talking trash and
then they two guys fought his whole
posse like em and I I don't know if he
got beat up I can't remember if he got
beat up but they didn't win and so it
sounds like they were outmatched
well his posse had like six dudes with
them and all of the plans was to come
and they didn't get they didn't lose
I'll just say that and so then the cops
come and I'm checking I'm curb checking
a bag and I'm watching all this and then
like the end TMZ's there and I'm like
and on TMZ comes back and I'm like who
is he and he's like Takashi six nine so
then I go to the clear thing and I go
hey who's the rapper and they're like
Takashi six nine and then one of the
girls goes he's got an album coming out
that's why he's fighting I was like
really and then I was like TMC was there
TMZ was already there before is
promoting why would he get his ass
kicked by two guys I think he was just
like it gonna twisted that better yeah I
don't know I think he's just from I
don't know I don't know anyway I like
they some I had friends go don't even
talk about him like don't even bring his
name up cuz though yeah people will kill
the Mexican Mafia kill you whoa yeah and
I was like bro I always just dude
there's a are you including me in this
[ __ ] now I was just when your
well let's follow them to the airport I
was like tell me how to make that not
happen to me just mentioning his name
without my Bloods telling me there is
some black guys dressed in red calling
me a serger skycap but yet and then but
then I watched like that was the
beginning of me finding out who he was
and then he's been like everywhere ever
since I've seen him everywhere he just
did a video with nickimja Nicki Minaj
Wow
Omega Manoj been getting out lately she
did this she's been kind of Cologne she
kinda have collabs with a you know with
a lot of people did you hear a diss
track about the guys she [ __ ]
so was that what you're saying that she
[ __ ] Drake
yeah and all those guys all of them and
I loved it but she hated it but I think
she I think it's I think it's a joke
like she tried to [ __ ] 50 for a powerful
hour but all he wanted to do is talk
power for hours like it's a diss track
of like I like all the guys that if she
did have sex on this Sunday I'd have sex
I loved the one she did about Odell
Beckham she was like something about I
wanted to have sex with Odell Beckham
but then I found what is it I didn't
mean to stop you in your tracks oh this
is so much better than paul Blart
you know paul blart mall cop I do this
guy's an actual mall cop his name's Paul
flirt and he what he does is he takes a
video of himself farting every day on
the job you want to start from the
Genesis or you want to start somewhere
in the middle I would like to go to the
one with the most comments just let's
scroll through 503 yeah
Paul Florida's born
he was actually fired dramatically there
was no video where they found his
account they're like dude you're fired
and he filmed the whole thing I should
probably know can you find that um in
this is this is a hot new thing this is
a hot new thing Paul FLARP and Paul
Fleur he's he worked he wrote we are off
we're off
not an just no I thought it said oh my
god oh my god does that have 74,000 wow
that was always why don't they show the
view cuz they're all videos I'm curious
how many people are watching these are
you percent real mile high person at a
time
Paul 14 thousand views I liked it
somehow one of these is somehow more
watchable and another one like this one
went viral but this one didn't get done
the composition was really the guy liked
to tell me do you know Bob memory uh oh
wait you don't know Bob Metairie uh-huh
is that Instagram thing oh my god he
makes me laugh so [ __ ] hard Instagram
comedy this is the grand Instagram and
he's where's this oh I'll hang on tell
me that I'll text you the number of the
for him to watch he does he just
comments on he does commentary over
sporting events but it's no Dan I opened
discord I clicked this horn doesn't open
I want to show you guys this video of
him getting fired
I would you want to watch that Paul
bought yeah find me that one this is it
job oh my god this is a costume oh
there's a real human being no that's a
real being those were real farts on the
job and now he's being fired
oh my no hall floor this is his job to
his viral fame is the title of this
video of what she up he titled this
video paul floor uses his job due to a
viral fame oh my god I wish I had the
balls to put that as a headline here he
said before you complain about vertical
video I was live on Instagram with his
hat
and they only support vertical to the
best of my knowledge hashtag Paul flirt
hashtag fart by the way now I have to
fart Florida ahead it alike yeah you
could yeah go ahead I mean I don't but
I'll just say like watching like and you
don't wear underwear do you right oh do
you need to use the bathroom nope okay
not anymore not anymore so this is Paul
flirting its Donna not much listen we
need to talk man yeah there's a bunch of
pissed-off people here okay okay what
are you doing I'm Gordon why are you
recording lark yes sir
no you're not gonna record me we're in
that uniform I don't you've set home
recording they said okay you could turn
it off okay well so you're firing me
anyway right yes if you're gonna fire me
I'm done okay so I can just walk out of
here right now
and then if that's it I mean if you guys
are gonna fire me
like what's well you do realize that
you're on a client's property yeah
wearing Adi Adi Adi you get the idea no
no no getting fired the guy tell him to
turn his camera off he's like no if
you're firing me I'm not running like
mine
wait I'm fired right all right I just
tweeted the one video from Bob mentary
on my Twitter page so if you go to talk
about pull it up I just this is a really
this one thing way of have no need to
open a video I'm saying it let me go to
your Twitter okay like it's you okay go
down and it's that right there that's
funny I love that okay you got that we
shall we share this is the way he'd
comment so it's is imagine if this was
the sports commentator for this okay and
this is not politically incorrect so you
get triggered just hang up
it's Bob's fault well Peter let's call a
spade a spade these guys hate each other
[Applause]
what's my name your name my name he does
he's you someone you can scroll through
his Instagram and they're not all about
what a Bob Bob man
and they're just funny like he's it
makes me I love it I love these guys
just out there making comedy yeah and
it's like it's hit or miss yeah it's
hard followers right and button normally
everything he puts out just makes me
giggle but the best is I'll be flipping
through them and I'll be laying in bed
listening to him and also my wife will
come at me like yo Georgia had an
overnight and he's [ __ ] yelling at
the top of his lungs put your [ __ ]
phone so tell me about secret time on
Netflix yeah right now streamable go
everybody has Netflix everyone does
pretty much how about got it on my phone
yeah that's a good pose artist thing in
the world is that my die said to my
daughters don't watch nefeli she was
down people watch Netflix on the ride to
school on the bus I know I'm like oh my
god so I'm gonna be me on the front page
and be like is this your dad click my
wife looks like Elvis was just an orgasm
but yeah it was great man
shot in Philadelphia at the Trocadero
did six shows tape two and
first show was mediocre when that great
and then later yeah yeah why show me
euchre
it was raining that night and are the
the generator went out and so we didn't
have electricity for an hour and a half
so the the first show had to wait in the
rain for an hour and a half and lose
their buzz and then we brought them in
sat them they're wet they're unhappy and
and it's Philly I don't give a [ __ ] if
you record your special [ __ ] soaking
wet go ahead my girl's hair is all
[ __ ] up and so then first show was not
the best it was okay was like an 80 out
of a hundred but when you shoot an
especially one a hundred yeah so I went
upstairs and I sat with my buddy Tony
and we had a coffee and I he left and I
was like I've always said I'd like to be
under pressure I love I love things live
I love the pressure of things I was like
trying to prove it and I went out and
literally had the best set of my life
one of the best sets of my life really
beginning to end I mean to the point
where I screwed around and I added some
[ __ ] and then I was just like I keep it
in my eyes and it was the best out of my
life and it went live last night and I
was looking like on Twitter you know you
kind of gingerly look and see like [ __ ]
what's something bad everything's been
good so you're just like all right cool
I'm good yeah just let it sit out there
live out there people can watch it and
enjoy it if you don't like it I think
people are at this point that they don't
like it so I'm gonna take the time to go
and hate it online so I probably won't
see that hopefully it's been a good
response and people like you guys have
liked it we love it Joe liked it I mean
listen we're we were like dying no not
to blow smoke up your ass but come on
you're you're one of the top guys
there's nobody that's gonna turn that on
be like this guys [ __ ] suck up class
dude you're killin it's been it's but
I'm very happy with it and I think the
real struggle is to make sure you have a
new hour so that when you're touring now
people come out to see you and they see
on aterial and so I got a new 52 minutes
so I'm cool so how long does it take you
to prep like a full hour like that you
know from for right now from Febby
worried until now so thick violence yeah
boss seems months to write a new hour
and so you spent how many just sound
great it's it's not perfect but it's a
new hour that I can stand and talk and
then from this six months till the next
six months
it'll get tighter and I'll add some new
bits I'll find some new transitions and
I'll make things stronger and then and
then you are you talking about your show
that you think I got the stand up show
me out on the road right now
the one I'm doing tonight nerve I'm
still evolving and so you're still
evolving this one but it's good it's an
hour of like new material if you [ __ ]
around a little bit on stage you have
fun in a moment little crowd work it's a
ghost and so I can I can cheat it for an
hour but and then and then at the end I
to ask whatever stories people want to
hear and they always know the Machine a
little machine flying dildos are the
ones and the next six months it gets
better and then you should get an offer
within three months after that to do
another special like 18 months is the
the period of that's the life the
difference between specials it should be
and so how is there a process so by the
time you're doing the Netflix especially
you've already done this show tons of
time yes so there's no rehearsing you're
like I know this so what happens is like
you I did my one special when I gave it
to you and then I wrote my new hour yeah
and then I worked it and I knew what I
liked and knew I had my one big piece
that I loved was the ziplining story so
that was like the center so I wanted to
work and the way Netflix works is people
only watch 32 hours 32 minutes and after
they say you know so I wanted to put
that in the middle so that if you were
gonna only watch 32 minute yen that's a
medium bit it's like a really great bit
yeah so that you go well [ __ ] how much
in the rest right so I wanted to
tentpole around that and so I think I
did properly but but what happened is by
the time I got the offer in like octa
end of October middle of October maybe I
got the offer I then said it's [ __ ]
on like I was like I'm taping it in
February the end of February and D in
Philly I did a hundred and fifty shows
with that our specifically well like
just you'd go out on on Tuesday do two
shows Tuesday two shows Wednesday in
different cities then go a weekend two
shows Thursday two shows Friday to show
Saturday right
and I did that cuz you want to take that
hour and you want to make it tight you
record it you watch it you find out
where the loose parts are with them we
can just see lazy writing then you find
a joke there
so you've taped it and watched it back
like watching like a baseball replay or
some [ __ ] yes some what it is is like so
you look at the whole hour and then you
go okay
this fits working this bits working in
this Brits working what's not working
then you find the one that's not working
and you really focus on that punch it up
make sure it's got an ending a middle a
beginning like but make sure that it's
rich it and then how do you still know
what's working if they used like you
watch yourself and you're you've done it
so many times like do you still know
what's funny yeah I think so when we
have to edit our own videos we'll watch
it so many times that we just feel like
we don't even know anymore I think the
difference is he's got an audience oh
[ __ ]
but it's like the small maybe so like
like there's really small things that
will sell a bit and you don't know why
it worked and so you have to go back and
watch the tape and go oh I did something
different in that we're done and then
you go okay that's now then then you're
like alright that's in the bit does it
ever happen where that you get laughter
but you're like that's not funny
yep huh that's an interesting thing all
right just keep it in your bucket they
like it there's a joke I just thought in
this but something any special the joke
is is it's it was just it's a throwaway
joke that's kind of cheap a little bit a
little hacky but but I thought it's fun
joke I almost put it in this special and
the joke was you know and I think's
really racist they don't make black baby
powder like they just make white stuff
like they should make okay and then and
then I say to a white guy like you don't
even get it like when you get a rash and
this is the line coming up I'll go like
this when the line that doesn't make
sense to get to laugh I go you get a
rash and you put it on and it just
blends in but when he gets rash on a
point to a black guy I go he's got a
ghost ride the whip it makes no [ __ ]
sense but it just a silly line no one
should laugh it's not right and I don't
know I love lines like that more the
wording doesn't even make sense of you
are like it's fine
yes so that's fine like I I had another
joke about black dick some in the same
joke I was like you think black is a
slimming color but is that the white one
should look big like a like a lighthouse
in the fog or a flashlight in a haunted
house and they go who are you kids doing
in here and everyone's like no that's
not how a flashlight in the haunted
house works what are you kids doing in
here and I was like ooh B do but yeah if
it works it works like you can't explain
you can try to find what makes people
laugh you just know it works the
lifecycle is you work it you work it
into this you really refine it like in
the most final way possible technical
way possible and you just hope that
Netflix is like all right we want it now
or do you kind of know that they're
gonna buy it at the wall at the end of
the lifecycle
no we so well I think there's two ways
to go about it one the situation I was
in is I had the our I told my agents I
got the our I'm ready to do it I've
recorded it I paid for a company to come
in and record it for me but first
professionally but not profession yeah
like someone like or like the Canon 7g
jo7 whatever 70s like they shot it
looked pretty I had it and I said I got
it to show to them and then they were
like they were like no we're good we'll
take it we don't need to see it cited by
it we trust that you can deliver and so
then but I'd already had a place I've
already dropped both to the truck to do
shows I knew I was gonna shoot my
special there but then I get the offer
from Netflix and then you go okay now I
can pay for it the other way and this is
the more interesting way and I won't I I
won't say anyone's name only cuz I don't
know it's not looked down upon at all a
lot of guys do it where they pay for it
out of pocket they pay for this special
out of pocket they shoot it and then
they sell it to Netflix and make tons of
money like I'll say a name of someone
who's like the perfect example jo koy
went to netflix and they were like I
don't know if they were like didn't give
him the number he liked or whatever and
jokeboys got money he does really always
done well he's got a restaurant Vegas
joke was like don't worry I got it
shot his own special like a [ __ ]
Stadium I think it's like a huge theater
then edits it gives it a Netflix because
what do you think and they're like oh we
want it and he was like I'll tell you
the price now
so then jo koy sells it for like a ton
of money I was in the it's different but
some people do that on a lower scale
mm-hm but with some people like Joe who
got the money they make it legit a
deliverable like we're Netflix wants it
I was lucky enough that Netflix wanted
to do mine out of pocket I've their own
pocket and so that's how I got mine
alright but even still you're on the
list of like all the big comics they
have coming out yeah where how important
you're gonna be on that list you got to
hope that they watch it yeah and they
like it right and oh you're your pre
that is this your first special that was
on Netflix yeah that's one and then and
then they liked it so much they bought
my second my earlier special then the
machine there was no time you're like
you want to buy that and I owned it we
will put that on to do this will air for
like three months and then that for like
yeah and then they'll be on for like
four years I think so the machine is on
Netflix right now and it should be on it
well it'll be on after this airs for a
little bit okay they want this to you
know kind of get established a fan base
and then when they put the other one on
do you benefit when people watch it or
day is it just straight licensing deal
Oh straight they own it I don't even I
don't think I don't think any benefits
just from know their rating and like if
they see that it does really well yeah I
think I get the right they own it for
like four maybe four I don't know that I
buy them i don't know the answer this so
but i think i owned it for like four
years and then the end of four years
they can either you know give me like a
real I mean real small it's a benefit to
have it on Netflix as a favor have it in
your pocket yeah like I think Tom's
first special when it ran out in four
years and I'm sure they were like you
could have a back and Tom was like or
you can just keep it you know some guys
like Bill burr like now I'll take my
library back and I'll own everything and
then when he dies everyone's like wait
how do we get that bill bird thanks yeah
you know but yep so low life insurance
policy I guess go burn but worried about
it were where would he have made his
fortune just from selling stand-up oh
dude he's really well he's tell
huge so he's playing in New York at like
like one of the huge venues he plays
like Stadium he has one of the coolest
stories he went into Boston and they
were like hey we want a bookie at the
Wilburn he's like great Wilber's it's
1,200 people and they're like great and
he's like cool you want to do well put a
show on Salem we'll see if we can add a
show and he's like all right so then
they put the show on sale it sells out
like five minutes five like okay you
want to add a show and he was like yeah
and they're like you know I sold off so
quickly maybe do you want to add a
Sunday show as well and he's like yeah
so they put this they hold the Sunday
show they put second show on sale on
Saturday
that sells out in my they put the show
on Sunday sells out add another show
sells out he sold out 19 shows he was
there for like two weeks and and he was
at home if you like stand at his parents
house and that is that is like buy your
house in cash money like that is oh yeah
you got a bill on your podcast and oh
let me organize that let me make that
happen we listen to his podcast like
Rick and he's and Bill right now is like
in you know the conversation we outside
bill one side that conversation with you
your brain is like because I well I
guess I won't I
I don't know how much I want to say on
the air about what we were talking about
yeah but I when I listen to his [ __ ] now
nobody knows anything what we're talking
about
I'm like not even doing the show but
when I listen to his agent know I'm very
him on on everything he does in that
realm
dude I list we have some food Bentley
he's everyone's like what the [ __ ] are
they talking about but everyone gets
different compliments right like so so
Segura's compliment he always gets like
sugar is not
approachable like no one says hi to him
oh he looks like surly bear like
whenever I'm with seguro people are like
you want to do things so go like oh [ __ ]
the machine and I'm like what's up oh my
god can you picture with your shirt off
and like of course of course
so I think my shirt how many days baby
with your shirt off today four times oh
yeah
and so and then then inevitably they'll
go like hi Tom and then they'll just
walk away dude we're eating lunch one
time we're sitting at a table eating
lunch and this guy's that next to us all
sudden he goes holy [ __ ] he's like Burt
oh my god the machine I can't believe
like he's like you're eating lunch what
Tom's a girl like I'm like a fan of both
you guys ago thanks so much
longest Amen we're try to eat lunch come
on loves you he's like you want to eat
lunch talk to this girl day and I'm like
oh my I love that so bill bill gets this
what bill guessed right so I get like
dude take your shirt off want to get a
shot yeah people look at suger and
they're like legit one fan said to him
on I'm not even joking on Instagram said
hey Tom I saw you in the airport and I
nodded and I apologize I didn't want to
intrude interview in a like get your
space yeah but I am a big fan and Tom's
like thank you he's a nice guy you see
him you say oh hey bill gets bill gets
guys who literally walk up like hands
folded like like they're meeting and
they're like sir you're the greatest
thinker of our generation thank you
thank you very much respect yeah yeah I
got father's back his brain is his brain
works like well that's when I listen to
his podcast it's like he's doing on
material but he's just talking about his
day and I'm just like how the [ __ ] is
this so funny dude he's just talking
about his day and he's like yeah doing
a plant like I'm like did he write this
is a nun's or epic his close latest
Conan was yeah someone wrote back I know
Bill guy I got bill
I like was harassing him and we got him
to use Instagram right so he starts
using Instagram by the way it's like
your dad using Instagram he's like this
is the sandwich I'm having for lunch
right and so Instagram use like great
Conan tonight I wore this shirt
and now it's in the rotation we got a
lucky shirt and I was like okay if Bill
burr thinks he's got a lucky shirt that
must be a murderous Conan yeah he's on
YouTube the clip you don't have the
whole damn thing oh yeah I'm gonna watch
it tonight I'm gonna when I go down to
the we've done the long one really how
long I mean it's over two hours it's
ready by the first one we did was three
hours dude went even to today it's
probably still one of the longest ones
were real I think the the longest one
we've done was like the chair do you one
though we were drinking really yeah that
was though that was a drinking one but
he drinks Bud Light so oh so it's like
water yeah yeah not like cigarettes it
was really hey what's going on with the
Logan Paul JP at ksi fight I'm man you
gonna pay per view it no I'm working I'm
just I'm working and it's Ellison yeah
you're gonna have this Sunday
you have to can't see your show yeah
guys porque si I thought it was psi oh
wow yeah it's kind of a cool boxing
this Logan Paul really I think he's I
think he's got some whatever ones he's
got I think ksi really because he has
experience and I think he takes
more seriously I don't Logan Paul hello
Paul doesn't have experience doing [ __ ]
ksi has had one boxing match that he won
he's been training he's very serious cuz
he make youtube video logon Paul's being
cute he's making YouTube videos ksi is
[ __ ] grinding do you know they're
gonna do one in LA they're gonna do
another one yeah we're gonna send us a
rematch no no yeah it's a rematch so
we're gonna send like Joey salads out
[Laughter]
people don't like that friends with him
but I'm like listen he's a solid head
lovable you might be you might have put
his dick in a hot dog bun
oh that's so great I think I think we'll
case Logan Paul is bigger and heavier
apparently I mean that counts for a lot
of law a lot yeah but ultimately I'm
pretty sure it's gonna be boring and go
the whole distance and be you know
determined by Joe be boring because
they're not monitors what did they know
they're gonna go in and do this stuff
that like like they learn like jab jab
jab jab punch jab jab if they went in
like one of those like we used to do ox
brawl in college where was just frat
boys with no training just going in
magravs and they were just throwing
haymakers just after 45 seconds you know
in shape but I think they're just not
they're not professional fighters what
can you expect yeah well you figure if
they're training they may be I've got a
little bit
Ellis manias this week jason Ellis has a
show on Sirius XM and two of my friends
are fighting Ryan O'Neal and Lewis J
Gomez but they're doing MMA they're
doing jiu-jitsu and I mean and so that's
the one that I'm really interested in
because Lewis J Gomez like they're both
comedians but he like left the comedy
long to end was like oh I'm gonna fire
I'm gonna [ __ ] kill him and like in
Ryan O'Neal's like hey it's gonna be fun
right where did the fight come from from
a rivalry or what is it I think our ISA
fear is friends with both of them and
yeah started it he's like oh you'd knock
you out Louis oh wow and then Louis is
Puerto Rican and he's like oh [ __ ] his
nicknames a Puerto Rican rattlesnake
he's like and he's and that's this week
- this week - well it's a big week
engine over this week I know tell me
about it I can't wait I can't wait
the best thing about Netflix is I don't
care like give my special aired on
Saturday I'd be like [ __ ] I'm losing all
these viewers they're never gonna see it
again but on Netflix are like dude go
watch all this [ __ ] and this son two
o'clock in the afternoon when you're
hungover make of it yourself a mimosa
and watch my special it's the best thing
about Netflix in Israel now really yeah
we waited so long in Israel yeah the
minute we left Oh Netflix in Israel I
watched this guy I watched this guy on
Netflix I don't know his name he's
Korean he's got white hair right he
doesn't speak English but he does
stand-up and I watched like 15 minutes
of his special just mouth open like more
of that I want straight-up Palestinian
comics like doing horrible racist Jewish
jokes
Oh Jewish people doing like but it's
like in their own and but at Netflix to
air all of it Somali pirates who do
stand-up Lorelai you're like hey how
weird is it boarding a cruise ship guy's
got shredders so [ __ ] cute look at
this I was about to say something I got
stopped dead in my tracks his eyes about
the clothes he can jump - yeah he's
quick he's nimble so we got it we got a
plan we got a plan dinner with me who
Tom and push my wife love love it we
should do we got to get bill burr on
here yeah of it and if it makes build
more comfortable we can do to me I'm
bill Barnes to make sure that bill
doesn't feel like it's gonna be like he
like builds biggest fears he's gonna get
like some he's gonna go in it'll be some
feminist blog so can let me be funny and
he's like what
but people just think like I don't say
yeah [ __ ] fear whatever one that now
bills go way to put words in my [ __ ]
mouth
but yeah listen guys secret time okay if
you want to watch a comedian one of the
best now living alive the funniest
people in the country right now Bert
Kreischer secret times on Netflix you
have Netflix the podcast is pretty much
over so you are you have my permission
to close this now at this point open
Netflix you can put on secret time
you're guaranteed gonna have a right
yeah one hour you're gonna love it I'll
tell you what else it's really so good
and when you're done with that Bert cast
oh yeah the podcast yeah love to it okay
let's organize love you're a website by
the way Bert Bert Bert comport or ticket
my wife just did redid the whole website
herself real outer space oh they're not
paying us this episode dad can you
believe that out actually can't can you
bleep that or nothing
[Laughter]
the one bit by the way we're good we're
gonna lock this up soon but the one I
was dying I was [ __ ] I couldn't agree
it the pajama bit was just I don't know
oh I just I just was like one night I'm
at this door and I'm just struggling to
find material like anything and I just I
just start telling the story and I tell
it and it does okay keep in the bar and
Adam egit who's the Booker and maddening
general manager now of all over the
Comedy Store just I get offstage like go
to that pajama jet no I go really
because that's my favorite bit you have
I was like dude it kills me and I was
like okay I literally had it goes in the
special oh yeah I was dying to breathe
oh I don't
but it was all just amazing amazing
amazing secret time all right
chrissake thank you so much Bert thank
you for coming on how to blow I'm so
glad I know I'm so glad this happened
yeah I've been waiting for this for a
long time
yeah thanks man appreciate it with that
being said thank you all you guys have a
great weekend I'm excited we're getting
off to Santa Cruz nice nice so excited
ready but yeah we're going what do you
guys leave tomorrow morning
oh nice I was thinking about going after
the show but I was like I'm trying for
the veal yeah
leave in the middle of the night crash
on the ditch my wife bought the one
wipin I did that one time we got camping
gear we went all but we were like we
still came to this weekend she goes
let's not get caught in the traffic
let's go it's a finite we Fla buy all
the stuff now we'll get everything ready
and we'll leave it like midnight kind of
like in the middle of the night it'll be
and I go great idea buy all our stuff
esporte shell lightly thousand dollars
with a camping gear get on the five
start driving up to Yosemite we got to
go to the bathroom and it's like 30
degrees and she's like we wonder what
the damages before cellphones are big
you wonder what the temperature in
Yosemite is no we get online it's like
10 degrees were like we got [ __ ] hard
the navigation we have a Tesla which is
part of the story I'm not saying that to
brag sorry they had to say that but the
navigation it doesn't use Google Maps so
it doesn't have traffic updates okay and
part of the so we driving up the one
which for anyone that isn't familiar
it's a road that goes all the way up the
coast of California and thrillers anyway
from like the center of California up to
Santa Cruz which is about two hours in
the mountains no reception there's
basically it's a really beautiful nature
drive but you're there's one road and
that's it
and so we're the navigation is taking up
up this road and about halfway up
there's just one lady sitting there in a
long chair one lady in the middle of the
road she's like hey
you got to turn around the road fell
into the ocean you can't drive this way
and apparently the roads been closed for
a long [ __ ] time and the Tesla which
is run powered by battery ok
there's no [ __ ] you can't be like hey
do you ever can I get a little gas
you've got a battery and thankfully we
charge right before going up the one but
like if we went up there and didn't
charge he would have been in there
[ __ ] but we had to drive back by the
time we got back it was empty again and
you got a charge ago we got lucky that
we charged right before because there's
no reception oh no [ __ ] gas what
would you have to do with you have to
get your car towed I don't know I don't
know I don't know your Tesla was like a
like a teenage boy with his headsets on
in the seventh house fire but the scene
there was one lady sitting in a lawn
chair in the middle of [ __ ] or the
road fell into the ocean I was like okay
oh my god I was like [ __ ] is the same
thing would happen with gas but there's
no gas stations around you my god but
you could like siphon some off or you
could wait for someone someone can come
I guess someone could just bring you a
gas gas as opposed to just like an
external charger for your phone plug it
into your car like but like how do you
call for a tow truck how do you do that
because you can't even charge there's
never again and and there yeah there's
no yeah there you do I was like well I
don't know what you do I think that's
when you storage don't you just jump
because we you take the insulation out
of it you start building a fire just
driving by cuz all these cars driving
around with gas powered yeah you guys
just moved there and get a job starts on
a course or subpoenas on the side of the
roll-up I can do this yeah guys have a
great weekend next week is Tim Heidecker
right yeah ah pretty excited holy
[ __ ] that's gonna be awesome we'll see
we'll see how that one yeah sorry ladies
we parked our jet skis outside so we
will see you then
yeah and have a great [ __ ] weekend
god damnit sooo good time yeah see you
guys on Tuesday guys Tuesday all right
right we do up still on Tuesday yeah I
was gonna hit him with this Albert
[Music]
[Music]